bonjour tout le monde alors bienvenue à
tous les gars aujourd'hui on a huitième
de finale entre Carlsen et gokesh alors
est-ce que Samy tu peux nous présenter
un petit peu les joueurs qui se
rencontrent tout de suite là
je sais pas si tout le monde connaît
carcène mais je vais quand même si tu
veux faire un petit un petit brief oui
bon donc le champion du monde qui a
renoncé certes à sa couronne en
classique mais par contre si vous
toujours montrer qu'il est le meilleur
en blitz sans Bullet donc dans cette
compétition speechers je crois qu'il a
pas joué depuis plusieurs années et du
coup là il fait son grand retour il
aimerait bien battre Nakamura a gagné 4
fois de suite en plus c'est une réalité
on s'est un petit peu entre Naka et
Carlsen donc il vient clairement car à
scène pour pour gagner le tournoi et
puis l'affronte un de tes petits
chouchous donc je te laisse le présenter
tu connais bien tu l’interviewé
d'ailleurs il y a pas si longtemps je le
connais très bien dans Google c'est un
joueur qui a joué pour l'équipe de
Cannes en Top 16 Top 12 à l'époque et
Google il a 16 ans il a 2725 kg c'est
juste stratosphérique et
illustriant il avait des supers
tendances aux Olympiades tout ça c'est
c'est vraiment en tout cas un joueur que
j'aime beaucoup et que je pense beaucoup
de joueurs l'aiment beaucoup aussi qui a
un futur vraiment
assez intéressant parce que un stage là
de 1725 c'est quand même assez précoce
de l'interviewer tu as pu voir était
abordable pas du tout la grosse tête non
pas du tout il est il est génial il est
hyper sympa
je veux un moment donné on avait joué à
un jeu je l'ai presque Fanny
mais il est adorable et il est très
sympa je me souviens pendant le Top 12
il nous était à nous préparer aussi il
avait 13 ans je te coupe une seconde
parce qu'on n'a pas assisté de la partie
dès le 5e
il a pas fait la tête du attends
d'ailleurs je me suis trompé de dans les
gars
je suis désolé c'est personne qui est
blanc et Carlson ne faisait pas du tout
la tête du mec qui a mis ce clic
on donne la case direct en B4 pour le
fou et mais bon après c'est une partie
c'est pas un petit clic qui qui donne
une pièce ou quoi que ce soit moche
comme quoi
je sais pas forcément le truc alors pour
te dire un peu parce que moi j'étais là
sur sur zoom dès le début en fait avec
cancel il était un petit peu enfin il
arrive à l'arrache il arrive à l'arrache
clairement
derrière c'était le bordel
il avait pas de caméra qu'il faut une
deuxième caméra pour montrer qu'il les
joueurs ne trichent pas etc il a mis son
téléphone et là je passe le loyer dans
la caméra mais il y a une chaise avec un
câble qui est branche son branché par le
téléphone vous voyez et ça c'est ça ça
deuxième caméra qui tient un fil comme
je peux voir mais bon je suis pas rabbit
donc je ne peux pas mon boulot mais du
coup en fait il a besoin d'avoir une
deuxième caméra et il avait rien et du
coup il arrive en touriste mais j'ai pas
de caméra donc il a pris son téléphone
enfin voilà c'est c'est
donc du coup il est un peu la rage dans
ce match donc à 4
ça
tu vois c'est le genre qui joue un peu
un peu vite quoi il a fait il a fait un
mix clic mais peut-être en stressant un
petit peu
ça donne un petit avantage tout de suite
à Google c'est peut-être pas mal parce
que bon imagine quand tu sais que tu vas
être face à carcène pendant plus de
trois heures tu dois quand même avoir un
peu la pression tu as pas envie de
faire humilier le million de perdre
contre personne mais tu as envie quand
même que le score il soit assez serré au
maximum
confiance peut-être d'entrer s'il arrive
à faire une bonne partie avec les Noirs
ça serait bien je pense alors bonjour à
tous qui nous regardent c'est du mala
salut le channel salut GB salut à tous
ouais salut tout le monde n'hésitez pas
dans le chat et des questions ouais
n'hésitez pas et
puis après
tu vois tout à l'heure tu disais que les
gens ont pas envie de pas forcément
envie de se faire humilier quand tu
comptes 47,45 il est vraiment tellement
fort il y a une grosse différence de
niveau entre lui et par un bocage qui
est encore jeune bon Google c'est un
monstre mais Garden c'est carcène quoi
et en fait je pense que la mentalité
vraiment indienne et aussi de goûtech et
c'est aussi ce qui fait que du coup
Google c'est un des meilleurs jeux du
monde quoi déjà à son âge
et ben c'est qu'en fait il a peur de
rien et qui s'en fout en fait il va
juste chercher
et ils ont un mental d'acier et et je
sais plus hier on m'a posé la question
c'était pas du tout en streaming ni rien
mais on m'appelle la question de savoir
si
Google pouvait abandonner au milieu du
match et en fait la question c'est oui
je crois qu'on peut en donner les 15 20
minutes de Bullet mais il le fera
15 minutes de Bullet mais il le fera pas
de toute façon parce que Google c'est un
Fighter et puis il a la chance de le
Carlsen et on part en privé quoi et donc
voilà lui il prend ce match là comme une
grande opportunité puis je garde et
aucun sens de toute façon puisque quand
il reste 10 minutes
à la limite tu finis par 5 + 1 tu es
mener tu vois mais là on Bullet après le
Bullet c'est marrant donc en plus tu
vois
[Musique]
sur le fameux Magnus tour le circuit
d'un sur Internet oui il a battu il a
battu 47
il avait il avait perdu en un coup
mais on va pas savoir rien dire internet
c'est tout est différent la Google il
sort de tournois tata style avec
Tata style India et il a fait blessé
rapide et je crois qu'en rapide il s'en
est bien sorti
mais en blé c'est la semaine dernière
mais le tournoi était hyper relevé
c'était hyper fort et puis le Blitz
c'est pas vraiment la meilleure cadence
de Google quand même c'est un joueur qui
est positionnel qui aime bien améliorer
la position faire des choses et
du coup en tactique c'est plus difficile
de jouer ce genre de jeu et
donc en tout cas on verra ça marche
hyper excitant hyper intéressant
et
45 qui joue avec une barre quand même de
connexion Internet
moi je m'inquiétais plutôt pour la
connaissance de Google justement parce
que quand tu avais son interview c'était
assez souvent saccadé on avait du
déchiffrer c'était assez galère
tu m'as dit qu'il était au même endroit
a priori donc on espère que le coup pour
le match ouais j'avais fait l'interview
pour trouver sur
interview de Google après ça ça médaille
d'or aux Olympiques et
du coup en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la BD on voulait mettre sur youtube
mais la connexion était tellement
pourrie que on n'arrivait pas à
comprendre ce que Google disait c'était
saccadé et du coup bah on n'a pas pu
mettre la vidéo sur Youtube donc au
final on a juste
par écrit on a réussi à plus ou moins de
chiffrer fin d'ailleurs même plutôt bien
réussi à déchiffrer ce qu'il disait mais
on le fait par écrit et on n'a pas mis
la vidéo malheureusement ça ça n'a pas
de sens en fait
on comprend rien et et voilà donc en
tout cas
c'est exactement de la même pièce que
quand je la mets c'est le même endroit
dans cette première partie surtout
malgré toi le misclic qui est quand même
donné à priori un avantage positionnel
au noir même si on n'a pas parlé encore
petit à petit c'est qu'à enseigne qui
est en train de légèrement prendre le
dessus bon la position vous voyez elle
reste très équilibrée il y a une égalité
matérielle parfaite et pas mal de choses
mais il a gagné un peu de terrain il a
installé un cavalier en C6 qui va
défendre B5 et ça peut être une petite
pression surtout voilà deux joueurs ou
quand même pas mal réfléchi donc ils
vont bientôt avoir un peu moins d'une
minute qui sait qui peut se passer quoi
donc peut-être que déjà on voit bien le
style de quarantaine qui va partir d'une
maladresse arrive à petit à petit à
transformer sa position
donc après la posture mais vous voyez ce
qui aime les blancs qui contrôlent les
colonnes ouvertes pour l'instant
et le cavalence aussi c'est le cas mais
c'est fort il y a la faiblesse en A7 qui
veut tout qui peut un jour être faible
et bon ça reste à peu près égal mais
quand même un avantage blanc quand même
pas négligeable
et je pense qu'elle est super importante
dans cette première partie un point de
vue psychologique tu perds par
typiquement tu sais que mon anniversaire
il arrive au début ça peut te faire déjà
un peu de mal après tu me dis voilà que
finalement
l'opportunité de jouer à chaque partie
et il bon il va faire de son mieux bien
sûr mais bon je compte 45 c'est dur quoi
mais je pense qui vraiment il saisit
l'opportunité de de jouer et de tu vois
pour lui c'est une chance quoi de par
trois heures avant en HQ avec un scène
quoi c'est c'est merveilleux quoi
intéressant parce qu'en fait les choses
d'un peu donner une case au Cavaillon C4
qui peut couvrir la colonne C de la tour
et attaquer le pion 3 donc ça bien sûr
ça donne un pion isolé au noir mais ça
donne des cases aussi au cavaliers donc
je trouve que c'est intéressant en tout
cas
d'un point de vue activité tu vois ça ça
reste quelque chose
très bien cette finale
déjà
j'aurais peut-être après si tu prends
pas c'est que je change pas les dames et
ben les Noirs gagnaient la colonne du
coup au final il y a pas préféré faire
cette concession tu vois et il a préféré
du coup leur belle défis qui a l'air du
coup tout à fait logique ok intéressant
du coup il décide de sacrifier le pion
directement pour rentrer dans une finale
avec un pont de moi mais au moins il y a
sa tour active derrière les pions
je pense c'est un bon choix pratique
après quand même falloir la défendre
majorité
F5 moi je pensais
F5 Google
et la tour qui va se placer au centre
et le H4 là c'était pour le coup la
gaffe de trop normalement avec la
technique Arsen c'est facile même si ici
en pratique ça peut sembler encore pas
si évident en réalité avec
là
il donne le plus grand pour pas sans
cesse après tu reprends là donc c'est 7
ça va être là il y a tout qui va tomber
absolument tout je pense qu'on peut
attendre là on peut attendre
l'abandon
et qui arrive
voilà je suis désolé je vous remets
ces petites comme la dernière fois la
petite scène speechers
c'est obligatoire
[Musique]
deux écrans alors qu'à priori les deux
joueurs
avec un Snickers
[Musique]
mais je crois qu'il va
jusqu'à maintenant oui passe du match
ça va être la pause qui va revenir dans
quelques instants parce qu'en fait elle
a une connexion pourrie vous voyez qu'il
avait une seule barre et enfin vous le
voyez pas mais moi je le vois personne
n'avait une seule barre contre 4 et du
coup ils l'ont demandé si
je peux revenir sur l'autre scène du
coup pendant que les joueurs ne sont pas
là
ce n'est pas montré
la part de Carcel je sais pas
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer plutôt
voilà et donc du coup en fait
oui la mauvaise connexion et il disait
que c'est la première fois de sa vie
qu'il a une connexion alors que ça a
toujours bien marché chez lui et du coup
ben il va essayer de reloger un peu tout
ça redémarrer la box et revenir donc
l'arbitre a demandé à Google c'était
d'accord bâton de Carlsen et la Bible
bien sûr je pense toute la nuit là non
vrai je pense ok c'est hyper chaud pour
le jeu contre contre Magnus pendant 3
heures et en plus bon c'est quand même
fair-play d'accepter enfin je pense que
c'est même pas cool de refuser un truc
comme ça surtout le champion du monde
les joueurs ont perdu à cause de leur
connexion justement ça arrivait par le
passé et ils ont pas eu de pas à droite
autant après Carson a gagné la partie il
a pas eu tu vois mais juste ils l'ont
demandé en fait c'est l'arbitre qui a
demandé à
c'est
l'arbitre qui a demandé à Carlsen si
c'était ok pour la connexion et il a dit
ben ouais mais c'est des problèmes je
sais pas pourquoi etc ça a tout un
marché là ça marche plus voilà je pense
que je pense que c'est Google qui a qui
a piraté sa connexion
donc on va voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe alors ce qui se passe c'est que
Yann qui te pose Carson qui a une
mauvaise connexion il va essayer de
redémarrer son ça box il arrive
mais du coup les gens on a compris ce
qui se passe en fait c'est un bluff de
Stéphane qui voulait nous faire croire
qu'on comprenne pas mais
au final il a tout capté
[Musique]
je crois la collection globale chez
Carcen ça bug donc on va voir en tout
cas bon ça ils vont revenir là je suis
sur le zoom
[Musique]
il a sa caméra qui active là je le vois
sa chambre là
et il est en train de revenir sur chaise
cam
donc j'espère juste que la caméra va
revenir et que je veux pas devoir tout à
régler comme comme j'avais dû faire lors
des prochaines éditions normalement non
normalement tout est bien je pense que
j'ai pas besoin de régler
et donc du coup Carlson qui est en train
et du coup j'arrive plus à ouvrir mon
truc là
alors qu'un scène qui vient d'arriver et
en train de mettre la caméra et je pense
que le match va reprendre dans un
instant
les joueurs sont prêts je vais voir sur
mon Obs si merde
si les caméras sont remises ou pas
est-ce que Carcen m'a tout fait bugger
et 47 m'a fait bugger je vais devoir sa
mis
les caméras en place
ce qui se passe et j'ai pas compris ce
qu'il a dit
tout le temps
[Musique]
une seule caméra et les gars ça va
repartir
attends je vais quand même vous mettre
je vais vous mettre la
scène il n'y a pas encore la vidéo de la
cam de Google je suis désolé ça arrive
deux secondes
parce que 45 il m'a tout cassé
elle a un peu blasé
ouais
je l'ai vu arriver sur sur
le zoom et je te promets il m'a donné
l'impression de blaser
on va voir
dans ce match toujours un peu
intéressant il y a des petits débats des
fois théoriques dans les ouvertures
si les joueurs varient beaucoup aussi
restent toujours à la même chose
en tout cas c'est du grand classique ce
qu'on veut quand on débute l'italienne
on sort juste les pièces on se développe
un spectaculaire
et
de prendre un petit peu d'espace à la
dame bonjour à 4 pour embêter le fouet
mais dans le genre de position c'est
quand même souvent assez dur de prendre
un avantage et ça lui Fatou
avec les Blancs parce que c'est encore
une fois très symétrique et du coup ça
reste très solide pour les Noirs donc
on va voir si la des idées et si ça
tendait à cette ouverture ce qui est pas
forcément c'est toujours c'est pas
forcément attendre
et puis en plus j'ai un genre de match
Carson il aime bien un petit peu
s'amuser je vois un peu de tout surtout
s'il arrive à prendre le large à un
moment donné
on n'est pas encore là on espère que
vous cache va résister du mieux possible
ça confirme peut-être tes propos
j'aurais pu parier sur le message je
pense que j'aurais fait exactement la
même si j'avais su que c'était lui qu'il
avait écrit
la symétrie il y a pas de Paris pour
l'instant on court
en tout cas c'est
en train de faire ah ok
je suis en train de faire les autres en
fait
c'est intéressant
il veut pas d'une symétrie parfaite
après vous promet 6
et on va voir qui est change les fois en
fait qui c'est le premier au chantage et
en fonction ça va pas mal impacter à la
structure de pion et du coup ça va
définir les enjeux stratégiques de la
partie
pour l'instant quand même assez plates
qui a joué à 5
peut-être un petit peu pour se venger de
son muscle de la première partie où il a
joué à 4 il avait un trou en B4 cette
fois il prend la classe B4 avec les
Noirs c'est un petit plaisir
on voit que 5 + une scanne assez loin au
début parce que seulement 14 coups
et oui on a vu que quelqu'un
par rapport
disons que vous cache il allait il a les
blancs il est en bas alors que sur
l'équipe
pour Google
je sais plus en quel sens
jusque là ça va encore mais
c'est possible qu'au moment d'abulettes
comment ça a fatigué la Migou cache
un peu bizarre qu'ils n'arrête pas trop
des horaires plutôt pour arranger les
deux joueurs non
que je pense que 17h 16h c'est pareil
pour lui ouais
aussi avoir un
audience
comme je pense aussi
salut thé vert
alors du coup cette position commence à
évoluer j'ai perdu un peu d'huile les
quelques échanges mais
il y a un pion qui a été sacrifié alors
comment il a sacrifié le pion
un qui a disparu donc ça ouvre la
colonne B donc les Noirs ont quand même
des compensations clairement ce que le
pion D2 des blancs est Ariel et fixé
quand même pour Google qui a priori
plutôt du bon côté de l'équilibre cette
fois-ci
on va voir s'il arrive à mettre la même
pression que qu'un scène lui a mis la
partie d'avant
et oui généralement il mord pour les
oreilles
déjà qualifié non pour les cartes de
finale
et d'ailleurs au passage le vainqueur de
ce match affrontera 41 au quart de
finale
qui avait battu irrigazi qui avait
galéré c'est très serré comme match et
c'est la partie de tableau de Maxime MVM
qui avait écrasé mes pots pour ceux qui
avaient vu le match aussi
peut-être qu'un scène en demi-finale
mais bon pour ça il faut que les deux
hommes arrivent jusque là
et un beau cavalier là F5 j'ai pas vu le
chemin qu'il est emprunté mais
ça commence à avoir plutôt une bonne
tête alors il va se faire chasser mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas le pion F7 qui est
prenable à se trouve qu'il y a 6 qui est
pro F7
ou alors est-ce que c'est un pion on
pointait
alors il a décidé de pas le prendre mais
en voyant la barre à gauche mais je
pense que le pion doit être Prud'homme
vous avez la recette complet parce que
ce qu'elle va dire qu'il ressorte
ça commence à être assez prometteur puis
la partie s'actifie un peu aussi le pion
des trois qui ont prises
il y a le roi noir qui est en danger ça
devient chaud
je suis arrivé en cours j'ai la je viens
de finir les caméras
parce que dès qu'il y a un joueur en
fait qui rentre et qui sort de la de la
Zoom est en fait ça me change toutes les
caméras les cartes scènes est sorti à
cause de ses connexions il est revenu et
du coup
j'ai pas trouvé ce qui s'est passé
c'était une espagnole italienne du coup
et du coup ça s'est standard ça ce qui
se passe ici mais il y a quand même ce
pion B2 qui t'a qui est arrivé qui va
être perdu et un super cavalier F5 pour
les blancs comme tu l'as dit
au passage
et en plus si le tour se venait à partir
il y aurait peut-être des idées avec ton
point F7 les petites tactiques
pourquoi le cavalier F5 il est pas
prenable aussi parce que si tu prends
cette tour reprend et en fait on va
menacer avec la tour à un petit mat de
l'escalier avec ton courage 5 qui a
l'air très très dur à défendre toutes
les pièces noires sont de l'autre côté
le roi est tout seul c'est dur de
défendre contre toutes les pièces
adverses donc il joue des cartes cartes
qui vont ouvrir la position et en plus
depuis le 5 serait prenable il y aura
plus tard la tour B8 aussi en prise
il met la pression autant car celle qui
a plus de 35 secondes gokash est
vraiment profite du fait qu'il a son
cavalier en F5 justement qui est qui est
tabou on peut pas y toucher et donc
sur case noire chez les noirs et ça
commence à devenir très dangereux
peut-être des idées pour doubler tout
ça pour la confiance ça dépend de X
non mais oui
c'est que j'ai fait comme ça mais en
fait quand il est sorti enfin quand il a
quitté la le zoom ça m'a déréglé mais
quand il est revenu ça a tout inversé en
fait du coup j'avais avec les planches
j'avais 45 et que les Noirs j'avais le
dos de cartes scène voilà du coup c'est
dû remettre ce bouquet de partout
et mais bon là c'est bon ça arrangé
était pris en R5 la tour me prenait
derrière elle est vraiment des réseaux
de maths avec tout reprend H5
sur un mouvement
ça va ma tête partout le roi serait
beaucoup trop faible parce que aucune
des pièces noires qui peut le secourir
donc tout F6 l'autre tour qui arrive en
F5 par exemple et ça va être matin
parable aussi qui est très fort aussi en
fait le roi est trop faible tu vois tout
seul droit est tout seul face à toutes
les pièces noires bah tu vois il arrive
par prendre le cavalier grâce à
abandon ça fait un partout alors ça
allait très vite à la fin mais en fait
juste il aurait gagné la dame donc c'est
à dire que ce genre qui refonte d'être
chelou
il y a un nouveau problème au niveau bug
enfin une seconde
partie je pense que Google
c'est vrai qu'il a 2787 c'est un vélo
pour rien
[Musique]
la différence
bon ça c'est incroyable parce qu'en vrai
dans ce premier set
hier en off on parle avec sa vie pour
les éventuels Paris qu'on voulait faire
pendant pendant le match et franchement
le Paris
les types de paris qu'on voulait faire
c'était sous le nombre de victoires
qu'elle est allé faire Google
en fait je sais pas
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que 45 il
est tellement au-dessus en fait il est
tellement au dessus de tout le monde
mais justement au cinéma il est très
long ce format donc car ça ne peut pas
être à 100% du début jusqu'à la fin donc
ouais il y a eu des matchs là il y a
longtemps là avec Kart 7 et en fait bah
il a mis il a mis 7-0 à Salem salé
il a mis alors je suis plus score mais
c'était des scores de ouf genre
il y a aussi perdu des parties qu'on
donne moins fort des mauvaises séries
donc
est-ce que je peux manger bébé
alors
tout début
mais là par contre
l'idée d'avoir cette structure plein de
fois il y a des positions on peut jouer
des sites tu sais que le pion pour pour
obtenir en fait sa structure avec avec
les Noirs il est en fait c'est que des
pièces auront du mal à sortir donc là du
coup
B7 c'est un petit peu long en fait
très déséquilibré il y a un pion de plus
pour les Noirs mais elle a perte de fou
et aussi beaucoup de matériels qui a
disparu de l'échiquier donc
il y a quand même aussi une belle avance
développement pour les blancs tu vois
que les noirs sont pas encore sur la
pièce puis en des matchs du couloir qui
peuvent arriver donc je peux profiter tu
vois un jour Foussais 4 vite attaqué
pendant que les Noirs en fait se
développent c'est pas facile du tout
pour les pour les Noirs en pratique il y
a un pion de plus par défaut mais j'ai
un gros retard quand même développement
et aussi des cases même notamment la
case des 5 qui par jour être contrôlé
par exemple
imaginons que la cavalier arrive en
dessin qui se fasse échanger contre le
fou de cases blanches et on pourrait se
retrouver donc
avec des fous de colorés et tant qu'il y
a encore la dame sur les gibier ça
pourrait être
assez vénime si elle venait à
disparaître beaucoup plus de choses de
nul mais on se prépare là
donc là il a donné la part de fou il
rend la part de foot direct pour
pour empêcher qu'elle descend qui selon
lui devait être un problème
donc ok ton B8 forcer il faut C4 vous
voyez car c'est comment il joue vite il
arrive à créer des problèmes directs
mais si c'est un coup je pense
pourquoi voilà pourquoi se priver de
prendre la colonne
très important je pense tout pour
dominer vraiment le foie adverse
parce que ça viendra plus tard voilà un
casque en fait le faux sortira pas le
fou c'est vite du coup il est vraiment
il met tout sur la case B7 c'est plutôt
bien joué en pratique x 6 C4 je pense et
c'est 4,5 pour calculer un peu ce qui se
passe
et ouais l'histoire sur B2 j'ai même pas
eu le temps de s'aller trop vite on a
pas vraiment eu le temps de calculer
mais peut-être
cette position et qu'on aura à nouveau
le temps d'en parler
intéressant en tout cas cette idée de
jouer à deux pour avoir après peut-être
éventuellement
alors est-ce que c'est qu'un va partir
je pense que ça a un coup qu'on a quand
même envie de jouer quoi qu'il reçoit
ouais mais après j'aime bien faire tout
droit voilà bien sûr mais il est ouvert
c'est un coup qui qui est pas stupide du
tout mais attention que roi F1 il y a
quand même des des
petits comme quoi
je sais pas un peu dans la saga c'est
pas évident qu'en posant c'est pas bête
pour jouer dans le C7 et aussi pour
comparer tout
merci à toi alors normalement l'alerte
devait sortir mais elle est pas sortie
l'alerte
pourtant elle est active chez moi je
sais pas pourquoi
je ne sais pas
à 4 ok en fait il faut empêcher baisser
4 B3 le coup de huile crushio
et de faire un étang il est vraiment
punir le foie si ça c'est intéressant
dans vos parties c'était pas pour me
poser des questions
quelles sont les bonnes pièces et les
mauvaises pièces et jouer contre parfois
c'est mieux de jouer contre l'adversaire
que pour soi et là c'est vraiment ce que
fait 47 et
il a réussi à jouer cette un jour mais
ça a l'air horrible maintenant après je
pense je prends des 6 c'est après cette
pollution c'est quand même pas encore si
simple pour le programme scène il peut
jouer 7 il faut prendre ton prends
tu prends des six roi F6 qui va défendre
depuis un exercice là et au fait la tour
ben la tour B7 défend les pions on est
très passive avec les Noirs mais il faut
encore percer ça potentiellement avec un
matériel réduit mais c'est vrai que mon
on a vu ce qu'a donné la première partie
c'est un peu ce genre de scénario
une quarantaine il a gagné très
facilement sa finale de tour
donc on va voir si l'application
contre Carlos va jouer ça avec le noir
ça fait pas plaisir
sans qu'il a étudié
moi ça m'a pas pensé à cette partie il
faut très bien laquelle tu parles c'est
contre winter
[Musique]
mais pour moi c'est pas la même parce
que la partie que tu que tu dis derrière
la partie dans le lit numéro 2 de Samy
et Kevin Bordy
mais en fait non ça n'a rien à voir la
position n'a rien à voir là ici le fou
il est quand même pas tout à fait mais
maintenant dans la partie donc par le
Nathan le fou il est le fouet
s'il bouge il est perdu quoi
et en fait du coup c'est vraiment un fou
qui est là en observateur
[Musique]
l'équipe et puis et puis je l'ai vu un
petit soir un petit câlin tu es content
les batteries là ça lui Arnaud ah oui
oui ça y est
[Musique]
je suis forcément
la raison parce que la tour elle est
complètement hors jeu en fait
le roi noir va venir colmater les bras
peut-être on sait sept mais il y aura
toutes C4 pour C4 parce que il y a le
pion
alors F5 ok il va empêcher ces quatre il
va empêcher les idées d'entrer d'un peu
de partout et beaucoup de la tour pour
sortir aussi
plus encore une fois c'est le pion de
décès une pion des 6 au choix celui qui
vous fait plaisir autant dire que ça
change pas grand-chose
à ma tour ici ta tour normalement pourra
pas trop partir de la de là quoi genre
blanche je peux pas partir genre
parce que des fois
forcément une des deux pièces blanches
qui va devoir rester à défense de pion
G3 et normalement le roi noir arrivera à
contrôler l'autre pièce celle qui
essaiera de pénétrer sa position il y a
la barre qui se ouais là-bas elle est
pas contente alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe
opposition et ensuite on bouge la tour
à quel point la l'activité du roi c'est
important au final ça fait deux parties
qui paient avec les Noirs alors que les
deux fois il avait un la nul quand même
à porter avec un peu plus de précision
au final et
et dans le style caractéristique de
Carcès il fait craquer son adversaire à
partir d'une position ou normalement
avec un bon jeu ça pouvait tenir
en plus
je l'aime bien celle-là c'est le
meilleur coup mais ok
c'est intéressant
dans cette position je sais pas trop
quoi te dire
des idées à base de C4 ici
ok c'est un coup qui a l'air de
ressembler à rien
l'idée c'est que tu veux faire un blocus
sur 15 novembre et en fait plus tard à
ta question c'est ça qui sera sans
défense parce que du coup les pions
noirs ne pourront plus le défendre
donc thématique si ce site en dessous il
avait joué le 5 un dans la première
partie avec les noirs qui c'était pour
mal patient j'avais perdu
quelqu'un qui avait très bien joué qui
avait Outlook à l'ancienne petit à petit
et donc du coup tout de suite il a
abandonné le 5 pour la Sicilienne on va
voir si ici tient dans les parties qui
viennent le 3 x 2
pour pousser E5
si je pars après
c'est un coup qui a été utilisé
énormément de fois dans le match je peux
la du monde un an de contre guelfand
[Musique]
la structure de pion cette fois et pas
du tout symétrique et il y a une colonne
ouvertes il y a un gros conflit au
centre et un pion h à la loi qui était
déjà aventuré assez loin donc il y a
beaucoup de zones de l'échiquier en fait
où il y a des tensions
à 4
c'est marrantes trois parties où il y a
à chaque fois ce trop embêt 4 pour le
noir
on dirait qu'il joue puissance 4
marrant bon B3
pour le cavalier
quelque part je pourrai plus mais la
structure en fait sur le long terme
cette finale est mauvaise pour les
normes parce que le pion A5 qui est pas
défendu par un pion en fait si jamais
avec les Noirs est-ce que ça pas de sens
pour toi ou est-ce que pourquoi pas tout
fermer
merci que généralement c'est pas un
super coup à cause de ce pion là mais du
coup j'ai pas le cavalier pour finir à
ta question mais
je sais pas trop pour l'instant tu
menaces pas avec les Blancs tu as
quelque chose de précis donc tu es pas
pressé de faire des gâteaux non plus
[Musique]
mais
je pense que maintenant ça va être mais
juste de manière générale c'est pas
c'est pas un excellent coup
alors
salut
nickel aucun problème technique pour
l'instant
on en a eu un tout à l'heure mais c'est
à cause de 47 de ta volonté pour le quoi
ouais donc ok donc
pour ce qui est des paris et ben tout il
ne gagne que contre toi Kevin je te
lâche tout de suite
va arriver je pense
à Samy
j'avais peur de ça et ça en fait ah bah
je trouve ça en direct j'avais peur de
j'avais peur de prise puis de Tours
c'est un
mais il a fermé le centre attends et
maintenant du coup ben les pièces sont
un petit peu enfermées je regrette un
petit peu le coup comme ça qui est
intéressant et même si on prend aussi
des fois intéressant pour prendre des
cases plus tard
moins moins clair mais du coup là tu as
une pression sur le sur C5 et même plus
tard des fois des idées de faire des
coups du genre Damme 3 pour provoquer
des cadres pour plus tard avoir la
cascade et toi ça c'est des idées qui
peuvent arriver dans cette position même
si l'attaquement ça prendra un pion
ok donc la tour simple je trouve que
c'est un poil dommage après je sais pas
pour ces deux
positions complètement fermée ou
typiquement on a énormément de temps
pour manœuvrer
que le centre il est il est clos pour de
bon l'aile dame aussi donc il y a que
Laura qui est susceptible de s'ouvrir
mais encore on en est loin c'est à dire
que les deux joueurs ils ont beaucoup de
temps ils vont essayer de réorganiser un
peu leur pièce peut-être le roi blanc il
va aller se cacher à pied jusque voilà
ou à deux comme ça
parce qu'en fait maintenant tours quand
même ça traduit
la volonté de phocéen plus tard devenir
peut-être plus cavalier contrôler cette
diagonale enfin F4 tu vois et aussi ça
laisse le chemin pour le roi en plus
qu'est-ce qu'il est
il est très créatif et je pense que il
peut clairement il est capable de jouer
ce genre d'idée
il est capable parce que là
normalement il sera plus rien ici du
coup tu as
c'est cohérent donc
comme annoncer salut super looping au
passage
de jouer F5 alors pas immédiatement il
doit le préparer parce que c'est ça
[Musique]
maintenant qu'il y avait tout vu
maintenant qu'il y avait tout vu F5
j'aime pas du tout pour le coup parce
que ça me permet de faire
ah oui mais bon après on fait attention
mais je pense dans tous les cas la
priorité c'est de cacher le roi
qui va jusqu'en B4 stouf là cette fois
le chemin il est clair ok il fait
impeccable car scène qui est qui aime
bien manœuvre cavalier il était en E7 1
2 3
j'ai l'impression que c'est plus les
noirs qui peuvent ouvrir s'ils veulent
que les blancs et puis ça peut arriver
en B3 toujours aussi
chez les Noirs il y a le foot 15 blanche
qui fait un gros taf quand même qui
manque un peu chez les Blancs
et non mais le plan des Noirs clairement
B4 caché le roi et puis une fois qu'ils
seront prêts et essayer de voir s'il
peut ouvrir la position quoi et le roi
blanc on sait pas encore il va aller je
pense qu'il va le mettre par là quand
même
c'est un client BK
qui serait gênait général
je t'écrase en fait faut prendre
salut
Jacques ouais c'est cool
[Musique]
c'est hyper intéressant en tout cas
c'est le meilleur moyen de gagner la
partie en un coup
alors F4 du coup a été joué
F5 et là ça va être
potentiellement verront intégral du coup
on doit prendre avec les Noirs non parce
que tu en penses
je sais pas parce que
incroyable
tarif 5 c'est vraiment absolument jamais
envisagé
donc ils ont plus de temps tous les deux
ils ont 30 secondes chacun un peu plus
qu'importe scène on basculer les deux
côtés ce genre de position
qu'elle va les prendre puis on prend
était trop Rodez un roi C2
si jamais il reste 12 problèmes de
cahier H4 qui est sous le feu de la dame
noire il faut F4 non je pense que le roi
va partir ici
ça défendrait de ces deux c'est
l'avantage
[Musique]
les trois pour garder le cavalier qui
permet à prendre des cases aussi
au final qui qui est à dominé par par
les pions les pions blancs
on n'est pas content d'avoir une tour
qui est vouée à la défense d'un pion
c'est un problème c'est clair
en fait
d'une façon une autre mais c'est
quelqu'un d'autre c'est intéressant en
pratique
c'est fou E5
personnes qui prend les risques
à la barre que l'ordi plutôt content
pour les blancs mais c'est
[Musique]
à ce moment là quand il y a plus de
temps à la pendule
[Musique]
de partout maintenant les fous sont trop
forts
[Musique]
comme on l'a dit c'était très dur en
pratique sur mon pour les blancs mais
après l'échange des dames ça va être
quand même l'air assez prometteur que
les deux pions passés je pense qu'il m'a
manqué un ou deux coups précis pour
stabiliser il aurait peut-être pu
égaliser quoi et du coup ça fait trop un
qui fait le premier trou dans ce match
le premier la première fois qu'il y a un
écart vraiment dans ce match
[Musique]
avant avant la pause je crois il y a une
pause d'ailleurs ils auraient peut-être
dû annoncer la pose généralement
ouais ouais c'est possible bon après les
joueurs sont
capables de jouer 1h30 sans pause quand
même mais je pense qu'elle va être bien
cuite dans les pattes de Carcès parce
que d'ailleurs il mange la banane il a
compris que
3h30 et j'ai un peu peur du résultat il
y aura peut-être d'autres en même temps
qui a rejoint la même ouverture que tout
à l'heure
ça a changé cette fois il a joué
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par là sur la
version des couleurs
j'aime beaucoup à 4 très créative de
cancer qui prend l'espace ici qui n'a
tour à trois je pense et plus tard
peut-être un tour H3 ça peut être
intéressant
effectivement c'est plutôt malin la Tour
Eiffel
je le sais pas
c'est bref
pour le
je ne l'ai pas là
la troisième rangée qui vient de vlades
exactement à la vidéo
très mal en tout cas je pense que par
contre Google je pense pas qu'il fallait
faire la même chose je pense pas que ce
soit
puis en plus c'est un petit problème
aussi sur la case à 6
mais ok mais après tu auras droit je
sais pas c'est le bon coup non plus ici
mais en tout cas c'est créatif
quand même pour passer pour l'instant
mais en tout cas dans l'idée vous B5
c'est surprenant
ben oui non parce qu'en fait il veut je
pense échanger
et maintenant je pourrais même mettre un
tour ici car plus le foot
ton but dans la vie de mettre une en
fait non mais en fait au niveau du
développement des Noirs bah on va genre
de set de la même si c'est un truc comme
ça quoi et du coup bah tant que ce qui
est changé les fous de quasiment chez si
alors tu as un pion en dessin qu'avec
les blancs mais bon au fond des trois et
pas non plus dégueulasse je sais pas
ouais
un truc à clouer faire un échec c'est
assez rare de voir un foie arrivé en B5
avec mais très souvent en fait je vais
faire le GSM aussi le fou il sera pas
forcément bon je pense moi j'aime
beaucoup B5 qui empêche aussi qu'il aura
8 qui prend le contrôle de gaz et une
fois que tu as joué à 5 tu vas plus trop
faire ces 6 c'est un peu tu es un peu
faible sur quasiment j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'il a fait ça intéressant avec ce dab
jakader qui coule cavalier F5 qui
attaque le fou G5 pose des problèmes
la tour à trois je vais je vais te
l'amener je vais te l'amener ici là
devant toi
[Musique]
assez mal et surtout il faut réussir à
stopper l'hémorragie et peut-être avec
les noirs pour vous cache qui a perdu
les deux premières parties que les noirs
si jamais tu as une couleur ça se passe
mal c'est dur ouais j'avais vu les
pronostics dans ce match il donnait il
donnait 15 caresses avec 99% quand même
encore plus déséquilibré peut-être sur
le papier ouais je pense bien encore
Google
la colonne ouverte encore une fois pour
Carlsen qui a l'avantage de la colonne
verte de cavalier qu'il a qui est plus
cloué mais qui a pas trop de cases vous
voyez que le cavalier il fallait nulle
part et si je fais j'ai 6 proposer à la
lame et ben ça va ouvrir le CASE noir et
ce qui
ce qui est vraiment en difficulté Google
la finale s'il arrive à changer toutes
les pièces lourdes ça devrait aller
cette fois-ci pour le coup
les plans sont mieux en plus d'espace
pour la colonne mais c'est pas simple de
vraiment alors le même scénario à chaque
partie blanche de carcène pour l'instant
il prend un petit avantage
il pousse il se transpose en finale et
jusque là il gagne on va voir si
ici la fin est la même ou pas
mais ça se ressemble
donc là il a il a fermé les quasiment
avec F6 hein
[Musique]
déjà il y a 2 minutes 46 pour 45 x 49
secondes chez les Noirs 8 va être l'idée
si il fait euro 8 ça peut ça peut aller
peut-être peut arriver maintenant pour
empêcher torroïdes
attaque là quand même
pas manger parce que du coup ils perdent
le pion 8
ça sent pas très bon encore pour les
Noirs quand même
et un jour voir ce qu'on peut faire avec
cette diagonale
il est un peu toujours avec les Blancs
quoi alors qu'avec les Noirs
si tu arrives à changer des pièces tu
peux tu peux au fur et à mesure revenir
dans la partie
donc du coup c'est pas facile moi je
vois bien un petit plan C3 B4 pour pour
45 pour se créer un pion passé
éloigné qui pourrait être très dangereux
dans la colonne
j'ai à 5 qui va arriver prise et on pose
le pion le pion le problème c'est dans
ce genre de se positionne noir quand on
joue ces trois V4 avec les blancs ils
vont être obligé de changer en B4 parce
que sinon le pion A5 va être beaucoup
trop faible puisqu'il est sur la couleur
du foie adverse on a personne pour le
défendre donc même si mesdames sur
échangées il y a encore de la souffrance
pour les pour les Noirs dans cette
finale
tu es toujours toujours en train de en
train de s'offrir ici
qu'avait pas de casse tu pensais pas
comment cavalier peut trouver une case
quoi
au passage
bienvenue à toi
donc
comment est-ce que je continue ici
avec les Blancs
et puis il y a le couple dame cavaliers
qui peut peut-être s'activer
[Musique]
comme tu es mal autant en plus
j'attends solide
plus ou moins
qu'un scène qui cherche comment
[Musique]
comment faire la décision salut Jawad
bienvenue à toi
alors cet échange de dames moi je pense
qu'un scène va garder les dames
apparemment lors du gagnant dans plein
de plein de coups possibles ils pensent
ouais l'ordi a l'impression que tout
gagne ici avec les Blancs paraît pas si
simple
à la longue il va jouer le plan qu'on
avait dit avec le
le pion passé
même quand elle n'a pas réussi à évaluer
que c'était gagnant pratiquement
attention ou dance de 5
et maintenant on peut jouer pour la
gagner mais
là il va tomber peut-être dommage 4
parce que ça ouvre le fou encore une
fois
j'ai 7 mais sous le clouage
des quatre il faut 5 à quelques secondes
c'est très très
chauds
sont très faibles et ça retourne
peut-être en faveur de cartes
l'option qui le pion qui avance
qui va arriver
[Musique]
et
franchement franchement ouais
ambulette on voit quand même le skill de
CARSAT qui qui est hyper chaud c'est
dommage qu'il a quand même gaffé c'est
la première vraie gaffe du match le
carrousel
et malgré tout il va quand même
peut-être qu'on peut rapidement voir ce
qui se passe dans cette finale parce que
leur donner gagnant partout et je pense
que l'idée
en fait la question c'est comment les
Noirs progressent tu vois que le
cavalier peut jamais bouger à cause du
pion là
à tenir le blocus en fait ben en fait
mon plan
c'est
genre aller on fait ça
que j'aime bien effectivement
ça permet de fixer le pion sur M6 et de
garder aussi les caches de cavalier donc
j'ai 5 et maintenant l'idée c'est de
faire de bouger le fou et de pousser tu
me crée un bien passé protégé c'est pas
du tout
si c'est possible genre ça
on va manger là manger là et faire ça et
du coup le pion sera perdu et si du coup
les Noirs prennent en B4
et ben ça me fait un peu passer éloigné
que je peux me créer et après
éventuellement remettre le fou ici pour
garder la le pion faible augmenter le
roi et voir ce qui se passe quoi et du
coup ce petit plan en final avait l'air
quand même assez confortable mon
ordinateur donne plus 7 et bien sûr
il aurait sûrement joué ces 6 voir c'est
5 le même après genre comme Cécile je
sais pas si la prise est possible
en C7 s'activer un peu mais le pion
toujours un peu faible peut-être du coup
je comprends maintenant un peu mieux
l'ordinateur qui est donné ici fou B24
pour garder vraiment l'impression sur le
plus rien six qui du coup empêche la vie
un peu ce genre de coup quoi
si on met le Cavaillon E5 c'est pas la
même mais
en tout cas bon ok très compliqué et là
ils avaient plus de temps là-dessus
c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'il avait
pris l'ascendant bonjour sponsor échec
et puis il a craqué dans le petit jeu
tactique à la fin on vous cache
et Billy je pense pas que Arseni soit à
l'hôtel il est peut-être juste chez lui
c'est pas possible
il a trois écrans je crois
donc
il est chez lui il est chez lui
il a un budget et tout je pense
la deuxième du match mais
malheureusement derrière c'est un petit
peu écroulé
il a 16 ans on vous rappelle il fait pas
forcément peut-être à la cam mais il en
a que 16 ans quoi c'est incroyable déjà
à ce niveau là à son âge
lui il est là pour apprendre c'est une
opportunités intéressantes
c'est pas vous voyez c'est pas le genre
de mec qui vient pour pour se qualifier
à tout prix pour pour prendre son fric
lui il est vraiment là pour pour
apprendre pour progresser et il a une
très bonne qualité et c'est un camp
Fighter et franchement bah lui il est
trop content je garde ça en fait
je pense qu'il a pas pour ambition de se
contenter d'encadrer sa victoire comme
Carcès à mon avis il a bien envie de
devenir champion du monde plus tard et
de le battre alors
classique on sait pas ça mais c'est
clair qu'il veut je pense que le jour où
il y a vraiment une nouvelle génération
qui arrive je pense que c'est
intéressant
un petit peu
indépendant enfin ça propre personnalité
etc mais en termes de trajectoire tu es
plein de il y a ça arrive il y en a
d'autres des promoteurs mais en termes
juste de Hello ils sont quand même très
loin de progression après
il a quand même trois ans de moins que
ça arrive
oui voilà il est déjà bien mieux classé
donc très bon sur Internet justement
pour le coup tu fais des grosses
performances dans les tournois basse
forme malade typiquement il y a déjà en
demi-finale du speedchait mais en
classique
plus de mal à confirmer il clique
exactement
et donc là on est à la mi-temps on était
à la mi-temps c'est ça du
5 +
130 minutes qui qui vont pas tarder à
reprendre là dans un instant plus non
avec cette histoire de ce qu'ils ont
décompté les Avengers
purement sur mon mycose je pense
après voilà généralement voilà il y a
après 10 parties qui sont jouées de
façon
entre 8 et 10 parties en scène que
généralement
je vais vous mettre le
set up là alors je sais que ça peut être
des fois un petit peu un peu chiant pour
vous de t'avoir à chaque fois
cette pub qui vient au milieu mais elle
est tout bien que
moi j'y peux rien
c'est le
salut c'est TF1 et écoute c'est un beau
jeu les échecs très riches plein de
choses
à apprendre un univers quand même dans
lequel découvrir beaucoup de choses donc
on espère que
ça te plaira et puis une petite question
au passage d'Axel comment on vérifie
s'il y a pas de tricheuse tout ben il y
a plusieurs bon déjà je pense que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui qui sont là
regardez le match voir un peu ce qui se
passe il y avait plein de spécialistes à
la matière surtout après la fin un imam
et en plus et ben il y a une caméra
vous vous ne voyez pas moi je la vois
mais on voit en fait on les voit de dos
on les voit de dos on voit et on voit
leur écran donc il partage
leur écran déjà à l'arbitre
et en plus c'est pas il y a une autre
caméra derrière eux pour voir un peu ce
qu'ils font et cetera
il a vu la capuche quoi après bon carne
et Google qui sont
très respectés et respectable
en termes de triche je vois absolument
enfin une confiance aveugle dans ces
deux joueurs
mais là pour le coup on a deux jours là
pour le coup
a priori reprochable complètement
irréprochable
donc ça va la prendre dans un instant
ça fait trois de suite
faut à tout prix arrêter l'hémorragie
je sais pas en terme de cadence si
le fait de passer en trois plus une ce
sera un avantage pour lui ou pas je
pense pas à mon avis va être encore plus
habile j'ai envie de dire que plus
s'accélère plus qu'un seul effort
généralement ça dans les meilleurs
joueurs calcule plus vite en fait tout
simplement
allez c'est parti
ok c'est parti et je vais vous changer
ce qui est mettre les blancs en bas
il a pas été invité un pas de métal non
il a joué avec les États-Unis le monde
de Paris
[Musique]
en demi-finale
la France
c'était les
[Musique]
qui a été joué
dans carreaux
qui varie ça c'est plutôt cool dans ce
match c'est que on n'a pas à chaque fois
la même partie il a eu 4 5 il nous a
fait une Sicilienne elle a une quarante
toutes les parties qui ont été jouées au
monde par cœur tu vois des analogies à
chaque fois
quelle culture quelle culture en attente
nous éclabousse de ces connaissances
moi c'est 5 ça va être un coup comme qui
va être joué un jour ou l'autre c'est
pas tout de suite j'ai pas de foudre
qui empêche le petit roc est-ce qu'on
ferait des fois en grand vogue au genre
de position ou pas
il va sortir cette pièce c'est standard
ça c'est genre position s'il y a pas du
G4 sur
moi mais il faut il faut voir
des fois aussi le four en F5 en tout cas
mais après il y a sûrement il faut il
faut voir G4 essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe ici c'est pour rentrer à la
maison c'est pas forcément l'idée
j'imagine mais ça reste quand même un
coup mais j'ai 4 ça reste un reste quand
même potentiel
[Musique]
qui sont vraiment devenus thématiques on
ne faisait pas trop encore il y a
quelques années mais depuis l'avènement
des supers ordinateurs alpha zéro
notamment qui est effrayant de ces idées
de pousser le pion h et aussi le roi
d'ailleurs mais encore plus souvent le
pion ah pour prendre de l'espace alors
même en fait contre intuitif on vous
disait quand vous apprenez au début bah
non touchez pas vos pions devant votre
or c'est votre bouclier et ben on voit
qu'au top niveau ils hésite pas pour
prendre de l'espace à pousse l'espion
c'est vrai que là dans toutes les
parties qu'on a vu quasiment il y avait
des pions H4 H5 et A4 aussi et bon après
dans cette position de française karaoké
c'est très standard ça a toujours été
plus ou moins standard mais là je pense
les H4 dont tu parles c'est surtout ce
qu'on voit dans la Grenelle donc dans
plein de positions de nouvelles idées
dans ma médiévov qui a tort jouer h4g4
et dans cette position c'est quand même
assez standard les cavaliers qui est
assez intéressant tu vois ils s'en fout
il tient donc il va crever
mais il peut avoir des problèmes avec du
GK justement à terme ce cavaliers c'est
assez intéressant il veut contrôler la
case c'est 5 empêcher tout ça mais si du
coup il a 2e la deuxième ouverture en
fait la il y a deux ruptures c'est 5 ou
F6 et donc là il a contrôlé la rupture
c'est 5 mais du coup F6 peut être
possible mais quand ils s'en fout il a
quand même fait c'est 5 alors que il me
semble que Google tout fait pour finir
le fasse pas
plutôt partir pour être si ce qui avait
l'air naturel pour visser
et à l'exerceuse ça donne quoi au-delà
du score c'est assez équilibré en fait
le problème de Google c'est qu'il a
perdu toutes ses parties à quinoa pour
l'instant et à chaque fois sur le même
scénario position il souffre un peu il y
a une finale un peu inférieure et il
finit par par craquer il y a que la
dernière partie où il a eu sa chance
a aussi l'air plus à l'aise quand deux
jours en moins de 10 secondes
c'est un facteur pour l'instant qui fait
la différence dans le fond de jeu il est
pour l'instant
dans beaucoup de parties il est quand
même
il est quand même au dessus j'ai envie
de dire
en tout cas il montre de plus grande
qualité dans ce match pour l'instant
alors après c'est possible qu'à ce
moment-là le match soit déjà tellement à
l'avantage de cancer s'amuse à troll un
peu mais au même qu'on 45 troll en
Bullet ça reste compliqué je vais contre
lui je sais pas s'il va drôle parce que
c'est gentiment te faire des ouvertures
de fois un peu il aime bien
mais après
tu vois les joueurs se font je pense que
Carlson il respecte énormément Google
toi c'est un truc ça serait pas avoir
pour moi tu as le troll en manque de en
manque de respect j'en vois deux donc ça
il pourrait faire contre un
un épaule mais comme ça ou un guerrier
um
mais
je pense contre un goûtage qui est quand
même hyper appliqué tout ça tient un
jeune qui va avoir
parce que il se retiendra un petit peu
en plus avec une histoire il y a pas
longtemps avec
je crois que c'était non
avec c'était pas cautionnellement
un jour il avait joué un G5 avec les
noirs et il avait pas abandonné que les
noms en premier coup
parce qu'il pensait que c'était pas
respectueux n'importe quand ça ne compte
qu'un seul tête qui va se calmer un peu
le sujet là
il voit bien plus que nous en 5 minutes
c'est où
pour essayer d'enfermer un peu peut-être
cavalier H4 qui est très malin ça prend
la casse du Caval tu vois il me laisse
fouger 3 vous êtes tranquille
[Musique]
toutes les parties et ben tu vois que
les deux joueurs en fait joue pour se la
coller et ça je trouve que c'est beau
quoi tu vois Google qui se laisse pas
impressionner et il va quoi et c'est ça
qu'on aime bien en fait c'est clair il
joue sa partie à fond et on voit ce que
ça donne mais ça c'est bien
intéressant je pense franchement que il
est là pour profiter au max et essayer
de faire attends chaque position qui
large chaque position chaque partie de
faire les meilleurs coups à chaque fois
et faire abstraction de contre qui les
ours on adversaire de tout ça et encore
une fois il est il est vraiment là pour
l'expérience quoi et il le sait en plus
dangereux je me disais que ok si tu
prends là j'ai Caval il prend et après
j'ai du F4
et si tu prends pas ben alors tu prends
un cavalier je prends là et puis tu es
qu'un vachement ouvert et les deux bras
sont ouverts mais le mien arrêtent plus
vite je sais pas c'est une idée que
j'avais pas F3
maintenant qui permettra de jouer F3
plus tard parce que du coup le clouage
disparaît et T4 de la part de 45 qui
veut en profiter des cases blanches
le matériel les gars c'est beaucoup
moins important que l'actualité
[Musique]
F4 f3g4 est-ce que je peux faire [ __ ]
et la première chose qui vient à
l'esprit
il prend le il prend case blanche qui va
tomber ça a l'air horrible pour les
blancs
aussi faible c'est très dur et Google
qui est encore une fois mal au temps
voler sur mon tableau d'affichage
c'était prévu
[Musique]
mais les fous de couleur opposés font
que il y a un ennemi immense
déséquilibre dans la position et comme
je souffle avec les flèches
qui est dans son tombeau là
je suis choqué
avec un sein de
merde OK
quand même salut Oliveto
salut à toi
enfermée mais bon
pour l'instant
ouais c'est difficile
c'est extrêmement dur en façade qui
intraitable
personne qui joue très il y a eu cette
deuxième partie où vous cache a vraiment
pris le dessus là bien joué et depuis
il est dominé dans tous les
compartiments du jeu en fait c'est très
dur alors ça c'est intéressant avec
cavalier des deux cavaliers
pour mettre le cavaliers
[Musique]
hyper intéressant
en fait pour ouvrir les cases noires ici
avec le fou
la jeune partie comme ça qui ressemble
un petit peu ce thème là une fois avec
les Blancs
qui paraît la case pour le cavalière
plutôt en C4
mine de rien est-ce que c'est 4 5 ou pas
c'est 90
puis on passe le protéger après j'ai la
même structure qu'une partie que j'ai
fait que j'ai publié sur Youtube contre
c'est le Road toemi contre l'Argentin
j'avais mis un Cavaillon en C4 comme ça
avec un pur face à la boucherie
hyper hyper intéressant sa position
c'est 4 hyper fort on a l'impression
qu'on donne la case D4 maintenant en
fait pas du tout parce que au final ce
que les Blancs recherchent à faire c'est
changer une pièce ou cavalier ici
comment
tu vas me tuer les bouffer lui changer
ok ouais
un mauvais coup est-ce que c'est si
grave du coup ben il va essayer de jouer
contre le trou noir du coup
genre froid et je te reprends enfin j'ai
trois G2
et
il veut pas que je veux pas échanger son
cahier contre case noire
[Musique]
et
mon fou il est il est vraiment trop fort
en dessin tu veux le manger j'aurais
bien passé protégé si tu le manges pas
bah écoute il est là et dès que tu viens
ici je te mange je pense stratégiquement
d'un bel avantage ici
donc
autant j'étais d'accord de prendre de
ces avec le cavalier
et du coup mon prono est le crushu va se
compliquer des événements
combien de points a marqué Google
[Musique]
en plus moi je l'aime beaucoup c'était
un de mes compagnons de d'équipe et
du coup ça fait un peu de mal
effectivement de travailler sur ça il y
a eu des gros changements là qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé les fous sont échangés
4 minutes
à comment résoudre ici le mieux c'est de
problème quoi
je te laisse faire ta propre pub ouais
alors moi je suis sur Youtube et sur
twitch et j'ai le même pseudo
malheureusement je peux pas me faire de
saut vous savez les fameux la pub là
pour mes pages parce que je suis pas
faire la plus propre pour moi tout seul
j'ai essayé mais je crois que ça marche
pas
[Musique]
comme ça
dans le chat c'est YouTube et twitch
vous avez tout je peux pas me faire
un truc est-ce qu'il faut être modo pour
faire le saut
on va voir un Artal parce que Samy si tu
vois tu es modo tu peux me le faire
point d'exclamation
et là tu auras voilà merci
je peux pas me faire moi-même en fait
et du coup là tu peux aller voir la
chaîne ça c'est twitch mais du coup il y
a aussi Youtube c'est la même chose
du coup comment ça se passe
la sacrifié pour espérer affaiblir le
roi blanc et choper peut-être des perles
des choses comme ça
donc
c'est concrètement il y a rien chez les
noirs
[Musique]
elle tient absolument tout quoi toutes
les cases
[Musique]
des trucs mais là c'est un peu un
sentiment d'impuissance
il est vraiment vraiment
ça fait déjà 600 malheureusement on
n'est pas au tennis c'est pas un
deuxième siècle qui commence on repart
pas de zéro ouais malheureusement non
j'ai pris les plus à prendre
alors le ce qu'on pourrait
pareil qu'on pourrait prendre c'est
est-ce que
j'ai pas vu avec combien les commencé
mais
Google c'est sûr
[Musique]
ça reste beaucoup je pense que je pense
qu'il est Ivan
ou pas loin de gagner un ou deux par
partie
je sais pas je sais pas si quelqu'un
peut nous le dire moi je peux regarder
mais après ça va
je devrais raconter
sa première partie comme goûter s'il
était à 97
il est passé à un des quatre on va voir
si ça lui réussit un peu mieux
encore une nouvelle ouverture une
nouvelle position donc ça c'est cool
la quand on change bah non parce que tu
passes en trois plus un du coup tu
gardes le MLO d'attendre
donc à 5 ok logique comme il y a une
tension ensemble à un moment donné le
Piton des 90 paraît être il est noir
volonté déjà à gagner le contrôle de la
casser C5 c'est pour ça que la 5 qui a
été joué 4
pris dans des cadres 6 kss5
tout hyper hyper standard hyper normal
ça c'est une position que j'aime bien
c'est vraiment structure pour les Noirs
c'est une sorte de destinienne veille
indienne quoi
si naturelle maintenant il a retardé un
peu son développement à la dame mais
sans dommage
et c'est peut-être presque plus facile à
jouer avec les Noirs moi je trouve ok
[Musique]
un problème sur la case champion B2 il a
colonne B c'est avec A3 à 5 de jouer
j'ai du mal vraiment
quand ils sont isolés c'est à dire qu'il
y a pas d'autres copains pion on va dire
sur les colonnes adjacent
doublés au final je trouve quand même
pas mal de cases avec mes pions
assez intéressant
et puis ça ouvre surtout souvent quand
on double des pions on ouvre des
colonnes et donc là ça ouvrira la
colonne B pour les Noirs donc il y a des
avantages dynamiques en compensation
et ici on voit qu'il tape sur le pion 4
maintenant
qui arrive
et ouais je trouve c'est plus facile à
jouer pour le noir ce genre de position
en fait on voit que les pièces
les pions tous des copains où ils
croient
bouffer toute façon il y a pas beaucoup
de pions qui se demandaient à la fin
qui est un grand favori dans cette
compétition avec Nakamura d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que tu penses toi de de ce
tournoi Samy au niveau des
au niveau des favoris etc moi je
pratique sur 45 quand même
en fait c'est pas compliqué Nakamura il
est quadruple ton nom du titre
donc ça pose déjà un petit peu
il a participé seulement deux fois et
donc c'est très intéressant la fois où
la toute première édition du speechs
c'est grâce à une qui a gagné et l'autre
fois au quartier doit jouer et où il a
perdu il a perdu en demi-finale et
c'était contre un renouvelle des grands
jours
là avant de perdre en finale plus tard
contre hikaro donc on aimerait bien
retrouver une affiche un quinzaine nvl
cette année en demi-finale ça serait
hyper hyper cool à suivre mais avant ça
bon il y a des matchs à gagner notamment
Maxime peut-être contre sceau au
prochain tour il devrait abattre à peu
près
un joueur intéressant aussi à ce format
le jeune est clairement mais oui
évidemment je te rejoins quinzaine Dakar
sont large favoris
c'est une surprise de voir un des
joueurs quand même
il avait failli batnaka une bien c'était
jouer à rien du tout il est perdu je
crois en Armageddon un truc comme ça
je crois que je me souviens et je ouais
mais ok après il y a quand même enfin ok
car c'est et
je veux dire en fait
vraiment dans ce
cadence tu vois ce format de match Peter
3 heures c'est généralement le meilleur
joueur
qui évite les surpris c'est vraiment un
joueur qui est pas en forme ça peut
arriver du match mais sinon c'est
vraiment le meilleur qui a une quoi
ouais généralement parce que franchement
trois heures tu vois Google il a gagné
une partie au début mais au final bon
sur le sur tous les meuble c'est dur
quoi
on a l'impression que c'est c'est un peu
comme une équipe de foot on a
l'impression qu'elle m'a jamais marqué
le but bah là on a un peu sentiment avec
goût cache des fois depuis quelques
parties on se dit comment il a réussi à
casser cette spirale et
et arrêter de perdre en fait tellement
on a l'impression que la scène domine là
depuis une grosseur
c'est vrai que il est assez
impressionnant en termes de niveau
il est beaucoup trop
forts
[Musique]
il a le bon style en fait pour les
freiner ces petits ces petits jeunes
c'est vraiment aussi le problème du
de l'heure quoi souvent il joue pas
forcément un horaire avantage pour lui
et
c'est clair que là pour le coup le
niveau c'est ce genre de petit détail
qui peut faire la différence quoi
est capable hein
cet aspect mental ou mais toujours
extrêmement en retrait genre les autres
sont bien meilleurs que moi c'est un
exploit sur les bars et toujours dans ce
un peu de ce discours
pour moi moi je trouve qu'il est plus
fort que la majorité des joueurs de
l'élite quoi je suis d'accord avec ça
moi qui est extrêmement fort mais tu
n'as pas envie de devenir champion du
monde par exemple d'essayer avec toi par
exemple
alors que par exemple moi je pense que
c'est un des joueurs qui pourraient
éventuellement battre car ça d'un match
sur le jeu je suis 100% d'accord avec
toi il y a juste voilà l'aspect
psychologique parce que il est on sent
qu'il est extrêmement stressé en fait au
quand il joue quand il est proche de
gagner des parties aussi tu as
l'impression même il souffre quoi
donc c'est vraiment ça ce qu'il a les
épaules pour mais en termes de jeu de
compréhension d'ailleurs il y a eu un
un match au championnat du monde de
Fisher Van Damme ou soit mais défoncé
car en scène je passe tu te rappelles
c'était impressionnant c'était pas cette
année-là c'était avant
dominer sur un match alors qu'il y a pas
de théorie donc c'était vraiment sur la
stratégie quoi
non mais
il est capable de faire de grandes
choses
assez
on va dire tranquille mais toujours un
peu pression
les noirs de pression un peu chez les
Blancs je trouve parce qu'en fait
toutes les pièces elles sont articulées
à la défense et à l'attaque de 4
quasiment
Google ça se pion B3 qui est une
faiblesse
B4 qui est encore une fois à être donné
à l'adversaire
et du coup le Cavaillon c'est ça qui
attaque à la fois B3 et à la fois E4 et
toutes les pièces sont sur le 4 et là
aussi les blancs sont aussi en défense
de ce pion donc clairement il y a une
pression sur l'option
mais ça ça a toujours été comme ça alors
qu'en F3
[Musique]
avoir envie de le faire
il a il a fait cavaler aussi pour
provoquer F5 maintenant il revient et du
coup
pouvoir profiter de l'histoire ranger 5
un jour peut-être manger d'abord le 3
est-ce que c'est pas Cavalo 3 qui a été
raté
[Musique]
et des trois c'était la tactique tout
fine effectivement
c'est pas de gagner sur une tactique
c'est de gagner en finale on a bien
compris
là c'est terrible regardez comme les
maisons fixées
incroyable sachant que c'est beau mais
tu vois il a toujours vachement
d'harmonie entre ces pièces toujours les
pièces hyper bien placées les pièces
actives et c'est vraiment pas la leçon
quoi car c'est il est vraiment à base
c'est un magicien tous les pions disparu
et cela vont pas tarder non plus à
disparaître
on voit les pions des Noirs étaient tous
en sécurité absolue et les pions des
Blancs étaient tous faibles donc souvent
on dit voilà il suffit de il y a une
seule faiblesse on peut tenir quand il y
en a deux ça devient difficile là il y
avait que des faiblesses forcément ça
explose
et ouais il abandonne pas parce qu'il a
soupçon
un petit piège que si il prend tout il y
avait H7 qui est la dame
est tombé
et du coup c'est la sixième victoire
d'affaire
ça commence à faire
on a envie qu'il en gagne mieux donc moi
qui fasse une nulle
autant
juste parce que ça casse un peu la
dynamique du match mais vu qu'on voit
qu'il est à chaque fois moins bien
autant on n'est pas sûr
et le moral doit être dans les
chaussettes je pense que c'est pas Fatou
qui nous contraint
[Rires]
mais voyez tu vas regarder encore ce
regard et cette envie de bien faire et
de bien jouer quoi et alors que tu
verrais peut-être un autre jour elle
passe à Google qui sera en train de
d'être
affalé au fond de sa chaise tu vois
il se bat et ouais ça c'est ça c'est
quand même à chaque fois il se prend pas
des ouais il se prend pas des fessées
ils perds pas en vaincu quoi
[Musique]
voilà il fait du mieux qu'il peut et ça
c'est vraiment appréciable tu vois
pour l'instant c'est normal encore une
fois ravie il a 16 ans de bouquet juste
incroyable data à ce niveau là c'est le
joueur le plus jeune évidemment de la
compétition cette année on a que des
stars
il y avait quand même beaucoup de matchs
qui étaient très très serré on a vu on a
vu Aronian contre contre André qui on a
vu
on a vu Ding contre grischool
[Musique]
était le premier à gagner largement à
dominer son âge
il a écrasé du coup
alors que c'était peut-être sur le
papier enfin c'était le choc
finalement
sur le papier il y a eu pareil il a
gagné à l'arraché
adversaire du coup le caresser
le cours de ce match ne vient pas à
changer radicalement
il avait sorti il avait créé la surprise
Maxime l'an dernier et je crois qu'il
l'avait battu grâce aux lettres c'était
la grosse surprise et là d'ailleurs il a
binette il avait surcassé Maxime
ambulette et ouais puis là il a aussi
battu Éric Asie ambulette
[Musique]
sur les pronos parce que là les pronos
étaient un petit peu bidon là
mais oui non mais c'est bon ça va être
un gros match bien sûr mais qu'un seul
favoris clairement
qu'on favori quoi quand même
il partira favori mais on en est pas là
on verra on espère peut-être on espère
voir ce match parce que franchement ça
va être hyper excitant un petit Naka
naka45 c'est quand même
il fait son entrée en liste bientôt non
tu seras en commentaire peut-être avec
Kevin Thériault c'est ça oui alors Naka
il va jouer jeudi soir
à partir de 19h si je le trompe pas
jeudi à 15h on a on a farine non
si c'est ça on a
on a Sarine guéri et
je me trompe peut-être pas je pense ça
rime peut-être favori contre Guérin ben
selon les pronos les favoris
de la forme des deux joueurs parce que
c'est quand même assez en fait guéri
c'est un meilleur joueur d'échec mais
dans ce format là c'est vrai
en IRL
un fameux tournoi au Pays-Bas donc il
est pas si mauvais que ça il m'a vu 2-0
mais il y a une partie où tu es gagnant
et
c'était de plus zéro et puis en fait
j'avais j'avais fait le ménage un peu
comme Carlson fait là il y avait le roi
de Google qui était au centre
et du coup il va la tour à 8 qui attaqué
madame H8 et j'ai oublié de bouger
madame
donc
j'ai laissé ma reprise
d'ailleurs juste pour vous dire ça a pas
mal tractionnel parce que là les matchs
étaient passés jusque là donc cette
semaine on va voir tous les matchs pour
finir les huitièmes de finale on va même
normalement débuter les cartes de finale
donc les matchs vont être beaucoup plus
rapprochés parce que voilà la finale
aura lieu toute façon le 16
[Musique]
ça va vraiment s'accélérer intensifier
et euh et ça commence encore une fois
pas sentir bon pour le roi de goût cash
on se trouve dans cette position qu'il y
a des réseaux autour de ça parce que
faut H6 puis on prend d'un échec
j'ai le fou qui va arriver le cavalier
qui est possible dans un M6 des fois
donc là on sent quand même que toutes
les pièces blanches sont dirigées vers
le roi noir tu vois
et sur case blanche et sur case noire
c'est ça qui est terrible
on décide aussi
compliqué compliqué cette ouverture pour
le coup autant jusque là il est plutôt
perdu petit à petit en milieu de jeu je
dirais mais là cette
cette ouverture ça a changé d'ailleurs
je crois pas qu'on avait vraiment eu ça
exactement jusqu'ici
c'est ce type de position c'est plutôt
très mal passé
c'est transformé une position
avantageuse en victoire et ce quel que
soit le niveau pour le coup est-ce que
vous branchez un coup parce que puis on
prend échec
voilà c'est parti il y a une tête de
calcul fout proche
il est en train de s'endormir
il est en train de se massacrer
et en fait là c'est vrai que sur roi A8
il y a du temps aussi mais aussi le
terme de la marche 4 qui a la assez
assez embêtant rouage 7 sur les Fouday 3
peut-être des fois
tout à l'heure hyper hyper compliqué
ça marche pas de métal bonne arme à toi
et merci d'être passé merci
mais non le Maroc a sorti l'Espagne a
exversale
d'adoption
en vrai je fais plus pour l'Argentine
que pour l'Espagne
d'ailleurs plus affûté du coup que les
Espagnols
plus la différence de but ici qu'il est
en train de soigner même si elle compte
pour rien si elle compte juste pour le
pour les gains financiers à la fin du
match autant dire que
que Carcès il s'en fout quelque chose
aussi j'imagine un peu moins caressé
sponsor il est jeune il est très fort il
a de l'argent il joue pas pour l'argent
[Musique]
et du coup il y a plus que 6 secondes en
plus pour essayer de défendre maintenant
c'est comment on finit avec les Blancs
je pense ça fait un truc comme ça mais
il y a toujours qui avait des F4 qui
peut être embêtant
[Musique]
il est pas là pour prendre le perpétuel
ici 45 il est là pour mater bon il a
fait une fois pour voir il a déjà mangé
trois pions pour la pièce sacrifiée donc
d'un point de vue matériel il est même
pas derrière
surtout si scénario poursuit quoi là
c'est l'exécution
si vous cache arrive un peu à gagner des
parties bon
il se passe quoi sur ça
j'ai encore
l'instant twin
la barre la barre se fâche
pourquoi
pas
possible ok
c'est absolument introuvable histoire de
donner à la dame pour jeter la douche
par contre comme thème de défense
en tout cas il aurait pas joué dans
cette ville aurait vu mais bon trouver
ce thème là c'est impossible
ok Sami est-ce que tu te pose
avant de avoir à faire une petite pause
ouais avant les 30 plus Sud donc
maintenant on va voir une heure deux
trois plus une
suivi de une demi-heure de une plus une
donc pour l'instant il y a 8 1 au score
pour 45 gros gros score quand même mais
bon merci GB d'ailleurs mais on aura des
petites pauses à chaque fois pour pour
nous aider d'ailleurs il y aura une
pause au milieu du segment d'une heure
qui est imposé par Tesla donc on verra
sinon la France en tout cas mais
mais voilà en tout cas tout de suite ne
partez pas rester parmi nous on revient
dans trois quatre minutes allez à tout
de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou si au contraire c'est encore plus dur
avec moins de temps la peur
donc
[Musique]
qui veut semer la zizanie
niveau très proche avec des styles
différents
[Musique]
je me suis je me suis voilà
et
moi on est
mais
on a aussi autant de normes virtuelles
un espace amis
virtuel
on en parlait hier on va partir je crois
de nombre de normes ratées par Samy avec
des pertes à 24,49
après 5
ans pour faire vraiment d'énormes mais
bon peu importe pas un objectif ça n'a
jamais été
allez c'est parti allez donc qui a les
plans de cette première partie
et direct ils sont genre peut-être il va
passer en mode je mets mes pièces en
fonction de kéto
et on voit après ce qui se passe
peut-être ça peut lui faire du bien il y
aura peut-être un peu moins de théorie
du coup
attends parce que là
il a joué dessin tu vois un coup qui
peut être un peu bizarre mais en réalité
c'est typique sans empêcher les blancs
de jouer à setup plus avec les trois
pions au centre
c'est assez typique sur cavalier F3 au
premier coup
comme Descartes on appelle ça je crois
que c'est la défense polonaise moi-même
essayé on part sérieuse c'est un petit
peu douteux des gardes il peut se
permettre à l'écran et appuie sur des
boutons
il y a la box derrière voilà
c'est le chat
domestique de stouf oui ma petite chatte
et donc du coup c'est bien c'est que
tout de suite il y a plus de rythmes
dans la partie il y a deux jours je joue
beaucoup plus vite il débute leur cours
et notre ami a placé toutes ces pièces
mineures à l'aile roi
alors il a plutôt pousser ses pions à la
dame donc on va peut-être avoir un
combat à chacun de son côté on va voir
qui est le plus incisif alors
généralement c'est position on est un
plan blanc F4 quand même c'est ce que je
pensais aussi c'était dans mon esprit
bah ouais et du coup ben l'attaque des
Noirs j'ai l'impression qu'elle est un
peu plus rapide quand même c'est
quasiment F4 comment tu fais pour
progresser parce que tes pièces leur
cadre elles sont contrôlées donc tu peux
pas avoir un généralement
comme ça
passe très souvent par une rupture de
pion pour prendre un avantage sur une
aile au centre pour créer une brèche
sans option les pièces elles sont
souvent un petit peu pénodes donc et là
il manque vraiment ça dans cette
position ça change
peut-être que maintenant il va pouvoir
prendre et jouer F4
pas trop fan du coup de Carlson
les empêcher de jouer F4
donc c'est pas simple défendre ce pion
F4 il faut être sur le soir quand même
parce que ça perd un pion
est sacrifier je sais pas ok donc là
s'il prend des trois mecs deux fois
dessus du coup maintenant tomber une
bien joué il s'enlève la diagonale et en
plus il permet d'échanger une pièce qui
va du coup
il prend des trois et dame bien non qui
marche oh je l'ai vu est-ce que je l'ai
vu avant avant que vous cache peut-être
d'un bain il y avait 31 ans il faut
prendre vite
j'ai failli en tout cas il sait que il
va récupérer quand il veut et que la
tour sera bien plus forte que les deux
pièces parce que du coup il y a beaucoup
de jeux sur le roi blanc et du coup là
il menace probablement faire ça à ça
celui de notre échec et ton C2 et là
j'ai des deux pièces sur le roi avec le
fou qui peut aussi arriver un jour
souvent souvent on dit que les pièces
deux pièces mineures c'est mieux qu'une
tour d'accord avec moi mais là c'est un
cas peut-être ou la tour peut être plus
forte surtout s'il y a ce fameux pion a
qui tombe et le pion A4 du coup
deviendrait extrêmement puissant en fait
là où deux pièces
c'est surtout en début de partie milieu
de jeu parce que les tours sont pas
encore assez actives tu vois dans la
partie mais quand tu arrives en fin de
partie la tour des fois elle peut être
bien meilleure que deux pièces mineures
parce que du coup bah une tour ça peut
être très très vite très très loin et en
plus il y a des problèmes de maths en
plus
on a trois etc
aussi c'est vraiment quelque chose de
d'hyper intéressant donc là on voit
quand même de coordination encore entre
des pièces entre les pièces blanches et
ce clouage qui est vraiment très
très gênant alors dame B5 n'est pas
possible pour l'instant je crois à cause
3 même si bon j'ai encore du fout des
cartes il y a plein de choses à regarder
ça a l'air pas clair
qui tient du coup le pion des trois
j'imagine il cherche le coup de grâce là
je pense dans cette position il sent
qu'il a gagné
comment conclure et il joue un foot
c'est joli impeccable je prends la dame
donc il y a un clouage
[Musique]
donc là où aller là où là plutôt en fin
je dirais mais échec sur la chambre ok
ça reste encore compliqué trois jeux
mais là il y a aussi un vis-à-vis donc
non on sait pas trop combien
c'est un coup sérieux mais ouais bah
c'est cool la partie
et pour ces deux et là encore une fois
il y a toutes les cloué c'est cloué
partout c'est l'atelier de bricolage
là tout est cloué le Fou est cloué tout
couler de partout dans tous les sens le
cercueil ambulant c'est juste l'enfer à
la position et du coup
très jolie il va manger à deux il va
manger à trois et ainsi il prend en plus
c'est pas il a perdu les deux pièces
et la pointe elle était quand même assez
subtile à la fin tu as l'impression
ouais mais je pense que Carlson quand il
va sacrifier la pièce il avait déjà vu
qu'il attaquerait à trois deux pièces à
la fois
obligatoire
c'est que avec les Blancs il aurait dû
sacrifier une de ces deux pièces sur le
tiroir et du coup ça aurait écarter avec
une qualité un peu plus en finale et
donc il a préféré abandonner gokash
allez première partie avec les Blancs
trois plus une pour le petit indien qui
va espérer du coup
casser enfin cette fameuse spirale de la
défaite
aussi
hyper intéressant parce que personne va
relever le challenge c'est une position
assez chaude qui va les prendre celui de
5 et 5 4 c'est très très chaud comme
position c'est très théorique je sais
pas s'il a envie de rentrer là-dedans
qui est sorti il y a pas très très
longtemps qui a été mis à la mode
j'ai eu quelques fois depuis quoi 4
mais par défaut pour empêcher ce que
j'aime pas ce genre de position de
prendre justement
ouais mais c'est pas évident parce que
généralement autant près ça peut être
compliqué
mais ok bon pourquoi pas
[Musique]
pour réfuter des ouvertures non plus
quoi
tu les gardes forcément pour des partis
plus
là bon je pense qu'il va je crois pour
jouer en fait fou ou 3
et pas se prendre
dans cette position très souvent et ben
on fait cavaler prend et on joue à 4 et
sur la 6 très souvent on va se ramener
un cavalier en B6 ça c'est très très
standard ces positions et du coup le
fait d'avoir joué A3 enfin tu tu
la structure la bonne changer depuis et
il a il a finalement fait à 4 hyper
intéressant ce qu'on fait garantir
j'aime bien ce qu'il fait moi je sens la
série s'arrêter je pense c'est la bonne
pour bocage ne va pas perdre cette
partie est-ce que tu peux bloquer les
cinq ou pas
j'ai pas hyper fan de ce qu'il a fait je
regrette un peu déjà
je comprends parce que sinon
ah faible à long terme mais
non
c'est une position
il arrive toujours à avoir des positions
faciles à jouer avec un scène ça qui est
fou tout seul juste il sort ses pièces
il a toujours un petit avantage
positionnaire
il essaye tout le temps de il essaye
tout le temps de d'éviter les
complications et éviter la tactique
et il le fait il le fait très bien
il est rentré dans des finales gagnantes
mais pour
OK
il y a la paire de fou mais c'est pas si
cata encore je trouve je crois
je prends mon pari
après s'il arrive à garder
le clandestine
qui va être possible et on sait ça qu'il
est quand même bien il empêche les
blancs
il garde aussi le pire
à 5
est-ce que
un truc comme ça
j'entends les klaxons chez moi
je crois que c'est le Maroc parce que
c'est pas l'Espagne je crois
et pourtant les gars j'habite en Espagne
il y a peut-être une communauté du coup
marocaine
en fait le Maroc c'est c'est très très
proche de Canaries
en fait il suffisait de l'appeler et
elle est faite elle est là
je sais pas si tu as vu sa réaction sur
cette fois on la lâche pas celle-là à 6
personnes là-bas
qui a donné et
[Musique]
ok ok bon ça reste quand même solide C4
là ils tournent autour
il est encore
et voilà il est mort de rire il est mort
de rire
il suffisait de l'appeler je suis assez
content j'ai bien fait de ta bête quand
même
je peux tenter à chaque partie mais bon
ça va être difficile pour le faire
remonter mais bon en tout cas c'est cool
c'est cool juste pour le moral et puis
la totale
première victoire avec les noirs qui
plus est il s'est pris la totale dans
cette partie
ça fait un partout dans ce segment de 3
plus une il a toujours réussi à avoir un
partout dans tous les traitements tous
ces grands
alors
deux parties de suite sans perdre ça ça
capuche
c'est quoi c'est un système de Londres
répertoire là aujourd'hui c'est le
festival on a tout je pense
elle transpose dans dans la carpe au
Canada
que j'ai que j'ai faite aussi sur
Youtube
exactement la même position que cette
vidéo d'ailleurs c'est un répertoire
facile qui est très très intéressant à
jouer pour les blancs pour ceux qui ont
la flemme de travail la théorie
cette structure pour les blancs en fait
et c'est hyper intéressant en fait
c'est une vidéo qui dure moins de 10
minutes et vous avez un repas complet
pour les blancs sur ma carrière
petit rock dans le plan ça de notre
cavalier enfin tout droit cavalier en 5
[Musique]
d'ailleurs dans cette 44
cette position je l'ai joué trois fois
en partie lente
j'ai trois la première fois j'ai gagné
en 20 coups contre un 1900 la deuxième
fois j'ai gagné en 13 coups contre un
2000 13 coups et la troisième fois les
juin 1500 qui m'a qui a complètement
fait au lit mais qui a perdu
une quinzaine de pouvoir
mais en trois parties la plus longue a
duré 20 cours et à chaque fois c'était
maths
mais l'ouverture vraiment vraiment
intéressante quoi tu peux la jouer sans
regarder quoi
et accélère un petit peu comme nous
faire remarquer dans le chat dans le
Trevor effectivement c'est des premières
fois je pensais qu'il est mieux autant
il a accéléré et 45 qui lui Ben chaque
coup il s'en va encore plus
neuf deux il aime pas perdre une partie
de toute façon ouais il est dit le thé
mais bon
c'est pas oui il a déjà plus tilté que
ça dans sa vie on est d'accord mais
juste par principe ça me fait chier de
il a fait une partie où il est
complètement passe à côté ça c'est clair
ça monte encore une fois qu'il est qu'il
est humain
beaucoup de points
chaque partie
dans cette position mais elle est plutôt
pas mal installé son Cavaillon le singe
il avait le sein comme il attend le pion
7 3 qui traîne toujours une vie de
faiblesse avec la case C4
il y a un incrément mais c'est qu'une
seconde donc ça reste pas si facile de
jouer avec un créneau
deuxième partie de suite sans perdre en
gagnant serait vraiment encore mieux
mais juste en terme de bouffées
d'oxygène quoi
pour autant relancer forcément le
suspense mais
qui va un petit peu
il va ouvrir son four
arriere en C3 il est transforme du coup
en une colonne ouverte bon maintenant il
a un pur isolant des cartes mais bon
et la position est ouverte donc
peut-être un tour aussi sans doute qui
peut arriver
quatre avec plusieurs pièces en prises
objectivement à peu près égale parce que
à cause du prix isolé justement il y a
la case des 5 peut-être pour un cavalier
qui devrait pouvoir équilibrer mais
mais peut-être plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs quand même cette position
ouais je sais pas mal
à faire les bons échanges ça peut être
pas mal pour eux parce que comme un pion
un pion un pion isolé en décape
à faire ça
de le manger
qui est prise
donc c'est un il empêche les problèmes
sur la première rangée
fois 6 place les pièces
comment on continue là
peut-être dams
une idée
pour les en manger en fait ce petit pion
là
sur le plan des cas des fois sur le pion
F2 des caillot 3 sur le roi en fait ça
peut être une idée parce que vous voyez
qu'il y a un vis-à-vis là c'est cloué
attention peut-être pour ces deux ici
mais
un couchage c'est peut-être le moment de
cette verrouiller un peu
4 avec les jouets j'ai même pas vieux
moi non plus
on a tout échangé je pense
c'est quand même pas simple
si tu prends j'ai échec
le roi blanc est très très faible ouais
il y a des F4 qui peut arriver très vite
mais après tu fais quoi si ça il y a pas
un bébé qui l'empêche la F4
du coup
ça fait partie des parties que Google
aurait vraiment pu ne pas perdre quoi
c'est dommage
et ce genre de partie justement qu'il a
posé pas le droit de perdre pour
pour avoir un score plus serré en fait
10 2 10 2 sur le sur le score général de
1 dans ce deuxième set pour 45
[Musique]
donc B6 ici
donc là on va un petit peu le même type
de position qu'on a vu avant avec le
pion C4
C4 donc c'est tout à fait logique donc
sont ouvertes donc c'est logique de
jouer le C4 maintenant
[Musique]
de parties comme ça il aime bien
généralement
la partie que j'avais analysé la partie
des Olympiades où il est battu
sargissant avec un F3 très très
intéressant
dans une sorte de
macadrer chacun
donc dessin qui a été joué tout à fait
logique
Cavalia 5 OK
vous deux peut-être grand rock qui peut
arriver à rock c'est
un petit projet
[Musique]
et je crois pas trop à ce que tu veux
faire
en fait c'est tendu
c'est tendu
F1 et je vais ouvrir toutes les colonnes
maintenant il y a trop de risques pour
gardien
parce que tu mets là il y a trois
fourchette
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que
ah non
pardon non je pensais qu'il est un panda
mais il faut prendre avec du coup je
peux pas manger les trois j'ai craqué
dans ma tête je pouvais faire
je pensais que c'était une dame en fait
ok
un petit peu
garde des options
et
aussi pour essayer de manger un pion
avec la dame pour manger à tout
simplement
vu son style en général il aime bien
tout en l'air derrière et j'ai 6 qui
était menacé donc je suis pas sûr
c'était
risqué enfin c'était matérialiste en
tout cas comme
complètement
[Musique]
fatidique et oui
on peut le dire j'ai fait gagner à
Google sa deuxième partie
c'est un peu bizarre son enfin son F5
soit très fort soit un peu bizarre
c'est pas possible pour l'instant parce
que là il y a en l'air il veut jouer
Caballé des 6 avec les noirs
des pions
mais attention aussi au thème
je n'en sais rien je l'ai pas vu le
match
du coup on n'a pas pu voir j'ai regardé
aucun match mais
mais du coup
c'est bien moi je suis content pour les
Marocains
un joli squelette blanc là
avec son fond H3 pour sécuriser le tout
mais
on a envie de sacrifier non on est au
22e coups
aussi pour la dame noire
est-ce qu'il y a pas de cahier
profitez de ce centre mais bon
je me suis trompé
le Maroc avait déjà battu la Belgique
c'est
et le centre des blancs ça y est qui met
la marche avant c'est ouf c'est marrant
c'est possible
avec le roi en E1 toujours aucun respect
ah ok et la F4
on peut basique quoi
il y avait un partout
et ensuite il s'envolait jusqu'à 9 1
mais par contre peut-être que cette
position pourrait tourner en faveur de
Google
c'était pas ça sa tasse de thé
qui a eu des parties qui sont juste dans
le bon détail mais il les a toutes
perdues c'est pas compliqué on est temps
parfois un gagnant donc
mais là on va tout peut se passer
quelques secondes il y a un pion une
casse de la dame les deux rois qui ont
réussi à se cacher un petit peu
il est tombé alors qu'il avait pris le
dessus
il avait caché son roi son de 2 était
bien protégé le pion 17 des blancs
pareil c'est plus proche de tomber et
malheureusement il a été trop loin
les deux parties de suite là oui
vraiment pas loin et
dans les dernières secondes il y a la
main qui tremblote un tout petit peu et
du coup ça fait la différence
enfin tu vois c'est un peu en expert
quoi
c'est cadence là aussi et je pense que
Google c'est pas vraiment
un joueur d'Internet quoi mais c'est
quand même par contre plus équilibré sur
le contenu pour l'instant ce segment de
3 plus simple mais clairement le score
c'est 11-2 mais en fait les parties sont
un matin assez intéressantes Go cash qui
monte quand même enfin il monte de très
très bonnes choses dans les parties et
c'est pas du tout comme on peut dire une
humiliation pas du tout
c'est à la fin c'est-à-dire que tu fais
une égale il résiste pendant longtemps
et il finit par céder mais c'est ça en
fait les les parties sont très disputés
et mais le score il est il est assez
sévère parce que bah il perd hyper
quasiment tous les parties quand il est
mal au dos
et donc ça fait un peu peur d'ailleurs
pour le Bullet Sami
tous les jeux se jouent aux égalités aux
avantages
tu vois pas sur le tableau d'affichage
mais au final
tout en étant très loin mais en tout cas
il y a eu une bataille quoi au niveau du
contenu
alors est-ce que avec les Blancs cette
fois il va réussir à obtenir quelque
chose
parti pour manœuvrer encore bouger ce
cavalier F3 pour jouer F4 à un moment
donné
et le pion à croire un peu faire un peu
faibles chez les Blancs parce que le fou
et de l'autre côté
[Musique]
et cette bouger les fous pour peut-être
jouer au 4 je pense ça va se passer par
là
qui mou comme ça dans une belle
diagonale mais en fait c'est la
diagonale du vide
et il peut pas du tout venir traiter
main forte au reste de ces pièces à son
roi allez le roi les pièces sont pas
très bien coordonnées et puis il y a il
y a eu quatre qui va arriver que le
vis-à-vis de la dalle mais c'est même
plus mettre
la foutu
mon fou c'est pas le mettre en mettant
et je ferme le 4 et après en fait c'est
juste c'est
de faire fout moi toi
aussi parce que vous voulez garder le
pire des cas de proposer pour avoir le
jeu 4
est-ce que tu fais avec les Blancs
des deux rapidement pour mettre le
cavalier en E4 pour empêcher en fait
avec les blancs ils puissent pas quoi
faire il charge des solutions mais c'est
dur d'en trouver mais en plus même
psychologiquement toutes les parties
sont comme ça
il a tenté que ça il était prêt il est
quasiment très beau le fou project
et bah juste c'est récupère le matériel
avec intérêt de pions au passage
il y a pas
mais du coup je bouge ma tour il y a pas
grand chose
très jolie fini vraiment un très tard
c'est la pub
c'est la pub chez pour FIFA il y a une
pause en fait on va dire entre les
joueurs et qui a été salué par
quincennes en mode c'est quoi cette
pause au milieu de nulle part
qui viennent de jouer 20 minutes une
demi-heure
on revient dans d'ici quelques minutes
pour le dénouement de ce deuxième cercle
donc c'est parmi nous ne bougez pas et
je vous dis du coup à tout de suite
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour je me suis
trompé les gars de
scène mais on est là et bien des mio de
cette fois-ci je me suis démioute
OK
et du coup ça va reprendre avec caracène
qui va avoir les plans dans cette partie
et le suspense reste entier on ne vous
le cache pas dans ce match extrêmement
serré il y a seulement 10 points d'écart
alors je crois je pars par quinzaine
donc qui reste 27 minutes de de Blitz et
ensuite on aura droit à une demi-heure
de LED alors karsen qui s'est encore
changé
et du coup
un petit rock doublure
salut François
bienvenue à toi salut François comment
vas-tu
en fait il était comme ça dans le
premier set après il a mis il a mis il a
mis un sweat à capuche et il vient juste
de
il fait il fait tout ce qu'il peut
franchement j'aime beaucoup la dernière
partie franchement en fait sur ce
segment de 3 + 1 une paire 4 ans mais il
pourrait bien avoir deux ennemi partout
quoi ça serait pas scandaleux
j'aime beaucoup en fait son attitude tu
vois de
ton Smart parce que bon c'est hyper dur
hein et il est là il se bat et c'est
vraiment faire ce qu'il peut ça c'est ça
c'est énorme comme qualité tu vois ça
traduit quelque chose
très très grosse force mentale à part
et François qui va aller faire le stage
à Paris avec Fab et maso excellent ça
fait pas de stage pour encore fait mais
genre je pense que je
ferai maintenant je pense en tout cas
j'avais prévu peut-être pour les
prochains
et pourquoi pas peut-être tu sais qu'on
va faire on va aller faire un tournoi à
avoine c'est peut-être cet été aussi et
du coup peut-être
essayer de faire une semaine avant
comment un petit stage de préparation
et profiter du fait que je sois en
France
et puis même l'été je pense que c'est
quand même plutôt bien il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont en vacances
donc ça peut être sympa un petit stage
avant toi peut-être
à Lyon je pensais enfin avoir
c'est Baptiste
que j'ai plus l'appart de Alpes
d'ailleurs je crois que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je crois
qu'ils ont ils ont tous démoli donc je
sais plus donc chaque propriétaire il y
a un truc bizarre en fait du coup on est
plus propriétaire de ce qu'on avait les
alpins
donc c'est dommage mais bon ça fait
quand même quelques années que je le
sais et voilà bon après après
de bien tu as la paire de fou là qui est
assez bon sérieux sur case noire
d'ailleurs maintenant aussi sur les deux
couleurs c'est c'est assez rare d'avoir
deux bons fous dans une partie abandon
il attend même pas de perdre plus de
matériel il est tellement
dans cette position il en a assez il en
a marre et il veut recommencer et on va
voir avec les blanches qui sont sort
mieux parce que là on est en train
surtout de suivre le scénario de la
première portion du match c'est-à-dire
et un partout puis ça fait 8 ans et un
partout et puis ça fait 5 ans
il reste 23000 dans ce match va dans ce
dans cette portion donc je pense qu'il y
aura le temps de faire plus de parties
que dans l'autre portion
et
donc un scène qui joue avec les Noirs
une sorte de Hérisson
encore une fois un double pion alors on
va peut-être avoir droit à ça jusqu'à la
fin du match pas impossible un quart
juste histoire que leur pièce il se
développe et on voit ensuite ce qui se
passe mais ça fait du coup il y a
vraiment une évite quasiment toute la
théorie
pour contrer le dessin qui secteur
d'échanger les fous avec cavaluer de
mettre un Cavalaire des cinq
assez standard comme ça je pense que
c'est cool
ou pas est-ce qu'il joue pour tenter de
dessin ou c'est trop dur ça marche
[Musique]
prise attention et puis on rage 3
échec reprend H3 et dans ma chambre
je sais pas si vous l'avez suivi
et du coup j'ai 4 ça fait plaisir le roi
blanc
c'est même pire que ça c'est Baptiste
non non franchement je pense que je
pense que Google il était il était
content
plus de potentiel que la Corée du Sud
sur le long terme aussi
ça c'est aussi c'est aussi un bon pour
l'instant mais en fait l'idée c'est que
Google
qui s'en fout un petit peu de l'argent
et de passer les tours je pense que là
je vais me caresser il passe 3 jours
Enzo avec avec
trois jours
c'est difficile mais mais je pense quand
même que il est content et c'est quand
même pour ça qu'il faisait chaque quoi
tu vois c'est pour s'affronter
oui non c'est clair en fait ce format le
problème de ce format en fait c'est que
dès que tu es mené comme là par exemple
le match il a plus d'intérêt parce que
tu es mené tu vas perdre alors que s'il
y avait par exemple on a déjà parlé
plein de fois mais un format avec 17 et
bien ça permet très de pouvoir avoir une
remontada un peu de l'espace que là
et pour l'instant comment tu l'as
mangent on n'est pas en mousse à 4 mais
bon
c'est que l'ordinateur donne davantage
noir
[Musique]
et en fait même l'ordinateur il dit non
mais c'est pour les
attention à ta tour
j'ai cinq donc là il fait défendre quand
même à la caisse il faut prendre ces
trois qui est une menace avec 3 2
et il y a aussi qui est pour le 5 il y a
deux menaces à celle-là et à celle là
avec ton coin à deux ça va être pris
hein maintenant la tour qui est
qui active
et le cavalier qui va se qui va sortir
pour fixer ce pion à 7
se libérer
la casse C5 mais après tu obtiens
qu'il arrive mais au moins tu auras pas
ton pion fixé donc j'aime pas du tout à
ce qu'il a fait Google
Google
avec toutes les parties il a il a 15
secondes pour 2 minutes
ça va ça va être dur je pense effrayante
un peu dommage après ça doit être dur
aussi à la fatigue psychologiquement
mais pas forcément hyper bien négocié
cette position
et du coup une partie qui pourraient
encore une fois tomber dans
l'escarcelles de Magnus et oui c'est ça
Fatou un objectif c'est de marquer un
point ambulette je pense ou la
fourchette
excuse-moi je vois un peu des
je vois un peu trouble
même si vous récupérez à deux
bah du coup il y a toute la boutique H4
G5 qui va tomber le roi aux cavaliers
d'ailleurs au choix vous cueillir
les deux parties c'était assez c'était à
sens unique c'est dur c'est très très
dur franchement car à scène qui est qui
est assez impressionnant
il est quand même souvent comme ça
typiquement c'est le genre de match ou
le format n'a pas de sens on est bien on
est tous d'accord on le sait depuis des
années
et la règle que m'a ajouté juste de
pouvoir abandonner l'image dans 10
dernières minutes de Bullet ne vient pas
du tout
atténué adoucir l'addition
tu penses que c'est toujours qu'on
regarde la scène tu as une micro sens
je me fais éclater
alors voilà je pense que je réponds à ta
question en fait on joue quand même jeu
enfin là juste juste c'est son plan cul
donc oui sur une partie bah écoute sur
une partie je peux très bien
et des fois tu peux faire une bonne
partie une mauvaise tout à l'heure qui
enseigne il a fait une partie là donc
sur une partie
tout peut arriver mais sur un match je
pense que voilà si jamais je fais une
nul sur le match je peux être content
quoi
il est juste beaucoup trop fort en fait
mais bon mais d'ailleurs car c'est déjà
une fois
c'était sur un tournoi
[Musique]
c'était Thomas
j'avais les blancs mais non j'avais bien
enfin c'était une partie qui avait duré
quoi
mais non il était beaucoup beaucoup
et ce qui est normal moi je suis pas du
tout je suis pas pro et je suis encore
moins dans le top mondial
donc merci pour ton message à la section
Z et du coup je t'ouvre tu peux nous
dire tu as déjà fait un petit peu
l'équivalent d'un speechess ou contre
Nakamura quelque part
pendant très longtemps et le speechestre
qui qui a
coupé court parce que du coup c'était en
3 + 0 c'était ça 3 + 0 il m'avait
c'était il y a longtemps c'était à
l'époque où j'habitais à Mouans-Sartoux
l'arcade il y avait défi un soir donc
c'était un mercredi soir je venais de
faire une grosse journée de cours
mais c'est la vérité parce qu'en fait
chez moi il est 22h chez lui il est 14h
et je viens de travailler toute la
journée et on a fait un match de Blitz
qui m'a défié donc moi j'étais un peu
crevé et tout je n'ai pas lancé une
session mais vu qu'il m'a défié et que
Nakamura te défie tu peux pas refuser
quoi donc j'ai accepté ça s'appelle le
défi et et je me suis pris un truc du
genre le score c'est un truc du genre je
sais plus mais peut-être 34 0 un truc
comme ça 34 à 0 je sais pas si vous
imaginez
et j'avais quand même 2800 et d'eau sur
le slam à peu près
bon tu perds 34 0
et pas que ouais mais bon après j'étais
un peu comme bouquet je me disais bon
allez enfin je joue quoi et en fait je
profite de l'instant je suis avec des
Français mais voilà et donc je suis les
Français et le lendemain même heure il
m'a redéfié
et là par contre j'ai fait j'ai fait une
nulle j'en ai gagné une autre
et à la fin donc quand je l'ai gagné il
m'a fait il me l'a laissé un petit
message dans votre chat très sympathique
d'ailleurs
et après la dernière partie j'ai une
tour de plus mais il a dû l'attaque et
il me propose nu parce qu'il voit que je
suis mal autant
je mets le temps oui et non mais je
commence à douter et ça fait deux heures
qu'on joue j'en peux plus en plus contre
lui c'est tout donner et j'ai pris
l'annule j'ai accepté l'annuler avec une
trop de plus j'avais du mal à mourir
dans la glace mais je dis je m'en fous
donc j'ai fini avec genre sur le match
en tout il y avait eu genre on a fait
60 parties et j'en ai gagné deux une et
ces deux nuls
et perdu 58 quoi voilà
et à peu près et après ce qui est
marrant c'est que
peut-être six mois après et ben il m'a
redéfié et il m'a renié
parce qu'avant ce qui m'avait fait
estimé pas et là il m'a défié et exprimé
il m'a défié un matin un matin chez moi
c'est le matin je me lève dans mon lit
je suis allongé avec l'ordinateur sur
les genoux au fond de mon lit avec le
touchpad et bon bah j'ai qu'un brevé le
défi avec touchpad et je l'ai maté je
l'ai maté Nakamura et alors s'il savait
que j'étais au fond de mon lit peut-être
pas je pense qu'il aurait été colère ça
va il faut il faudra pas lui dire mais
du coup voilà donc au final je l'ai
battu quoi trois fois non ouais environ
deux ou trois fois je sais même plus il
a la colère faciale
et
il a quitté le string
au milieu de la partie
le score c'est la folie c'est fin juste
60 et quelques à deux quoi
pire que carcène par rapport à ça je
pense en fait ça là
longtemps qui fatigue pas oui mais en
fait en plus il veut te défoncer en fait
lui pour le coup il veut te défoncer
alors que karassen vont à un moment il
va rater
vraiment malgré les 15 0 20 0 30 0 qui
avait j'ai essayé vraiment d'être focus
et de et de gagner une quand il veut
sauver le nord et ouais j'ai essayé de
partir c'est d'être focus mais c'était
un vlogue
je pense que quelqu'un aussi c'est que
les parce que ça arrive quand même dans
l'eau ou des fois où tu es gagnant ou tu
es très bien mais ce qui va tellement
réussir à te faire tomber ça m'est
arrivé plein de fois qu'il me faisait
tomber dans la prochaine gagnante il va
jouer mais pendant 40 coups pour te
faire tomber il va rien lâcher ben oui
moi il y avait il y avait une partie où
j'avais il avait un cavalier j'avais un
pion
une de plus donc là bon
du coup c'est original
j'avais déjà vu notamment
[Musique]
du coup moralité de l'histoire voilà
vous jouez contre un mec vraiment très
fort bah essayez vraiment de bonne
profiter quoi
et juste faites-vous plaisir quoi
simplement
elle est où l'épée de Fatou
Dre
[Musique]
je sens bien que Google ne va pas perdre
cette partie
la deuxième fois du match que alors
cette fois-ci la position est en plus
prometteur que la fourche la vesti avant
mais on va avoir alors là
franchement
qui pourra venir un jour en ces quatre
et il y a aussi une pièce qui est en
prise hein
donc quand même des menaces concrètes
alors qu'on a je commence où et que le
développement
qui se met à réfléchir pour trouver des
solutions donc il laisse faut prendre un
fils toi je pense il veut jouer actif
ça peut chauffer tactiquement
je suis obligé de manger oui je pense
non je pensais un carré pour F2
actives ça me plaisait pas
fait trier et là maintenant prise parce
que c'est tout à fait débile
[Musique]
et je pense peut-être une petite erreur
tu vois c'est il a pris en 4 vide et
maintenant il réfléchit longtemps ouais
vraiment en terme de façon de séquencer
notre réflexion si on prend une pièce
que l'autre on sait qu'il va la
reprendre je vais derrière le coup assez
vite que ça veut dire qu'il a dû rater
quelque chose ils sont des rendus compte
peut-être
du coup il a peut-être racheté sa chance
hein dans cette partie j'ai l'impression
même si bien sûr tout reste ouvert mais
ça reste très compliqué
il reviendra plus quoi
alors
parce que tu vois là E5 il y aura d'un
point F5 sur échec après ca va les
prendre des 5 je me lassais quand même
la porte devant des fous la CO3 il a
préféré manger comme ça pour ouvrir un
peu plus la position le trop obligatoire
et maintenant il va venir attaquer avec
ces pièces
la position reste je pense à double
tranchant
peut se passer surtout avec le temps et
pour une fois il est mis au temps ça
c'est quand même pas fréquent
attention à cette thème et F3 c'est
marrant ou qu'est-ce qui va son temps
peut-être des pions triplés pour faire
plaisir au chat
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup de points
tous les 3 C5 peut-être qu'il est temps
de manger au 4
là il faut manger une robe marrante avec
ces quatre puis on prend puis on prend
F6
[Musique]
c'est quand même des menaces
pour le coup
très drôle l'ordinateur
ça peut aussi perdre autant à tout
moment
la moindre erreur ici c'est fatal
a craqué
peut-être ou attention que surprise je
prends quoi
ok ça va trop vite
là c'est beaucoup trop de partout
c'est pas qui est lièvre qui est la
tortue et on dirait que que le quinzaine
est pour une fois c'est transformé en
tortue non
[Musique]
c'est lui qui a fait dab mon premier
donc qui avait la main il a lâché la
main en faisant un coup droit pour mener
ses maths sauf qu'il a mis son roi sur
la case où il s'est pris un bâton d'un
coup alors qu'il pouvait faire des
échecs il avait certainement
ça fait très mal
je pense que j'aurais cassé la souris
perso
en plus quand il l'a fait peut-être
qu'il avait même primo secours et que et
que
il a pu cliquer au hasard le matin
il est en train de repenser la position
c'était quoi le coup parce qu'on aime
bien en tant que joueur d'échec
juste pour pour au moins un petit peu
s'apaiser son cerveau c'était quoi le
bon coup pour que le matte en fait
[Musique]
c'est sûr
et en plus du coup il a gagné durable
une dernière partie
de 3 plus une pour peut-être faire bien
donc on s'aime plus du tout ce qui
faisait tous les deux tu vois la
majorité 45
la finale de fou là elle était
compliqué avec aussi peu de temps il
trouve des idées des deux côtés alors
que nous on aurait fait nul sans même la
jouer tu vois enfin je trouve que ils
sont tellement forts pour créer des
choses salut sinon quoi
c'est hallucinant
donc
j'avais oublié de changer
le plus grand écart de l'histoire du
pichet ou je sais pas si tu sais ben je
pense que c'est ma caméra contre oui fan
assez construit ok
c'était du
[Musique]
25 à 2
il y avait deux places il y avait 14
invités et deux places canification par
des tours droits du coup sur cheesecom
et grichou qui était pas dans les
invités quand même qui a du gainer son
ticket avant de perdre contreding et pas
raviale qui a gagné l'autre ticket par
exemple qu'un grand maître russe qui
aime très fort mais ça
Nakamura risque de pas
peser bien lourd
27,5
[Musique]
c'est normal c'est
enfin c'est presque on peut dire comme
si nous on joue quasiment un peu plus
fort mais c'est pas le plus c'est le
même sphère quoi on va dire
donc forcément on va faire un match
comme ça pendant trois heures à partir
sympa au même au même monde en fait
alors que oui fan c'est quand même après
Paul gars la meilleure chose de tous les
temps
des études brillantes c'était genre la
plus jeune
chinoise peut-être il me semble à
devenir enfin réussir tel concours enfin
quelque chose comme ça
dans la meilleure école de Chine elle
s'est débrouillée
on parle on parle on parle mais Google
je suis en train de la colocation
depuis la partie tout à l'heure quand
même
[Musique]
il a beaucoup de temps de plus tout le
temps
donc ça peut encore mal tourner c'est
vrai
la confiance c'est tout difficile
d'accord
s
[Musique]
mvl en fait
c'est pas
enfin c'est un gros score mais en fait
c'est de meilleurs jours les scores
peuvent traverser en fait ça c'est
quand même assez
les joueurs sont assez égaux il y a pas
de niveau oui mais bien sûr c'est plus
une star de forme du moment là pour le
contre c'est ça
peut paraître bon Carême est un meilleur
de manière générale
il a juste une pièce non c'est une pièce
il rigole
il est abandonné ou pas non non non
[Musique]
globalement
c'était plus
un peu plus on va dire serrer sur le
contenu même si bien sûr à l'écart reste
grand
et du coup ok carton qui mène du coup 16
à 3 maintenant et
du coup du coup il reste cette dernière
portion en une plus une qui va commencer
dans une pardon dans 5 minutes et qui
durera du coup une demi-heure
donc
comment on finir en beauté pour finir en
beauté qu'est-ce que tu penses
marqué trois points cette fois-ci
qu'est-ce que tu penses du Bullet
le pire segment pour vous dans le pire
c'est dur de faire pire que vite
ouais j'ai un peu peur j'ai l'impression
que il a du mal quand même par rapport à
carcène quand on est deux jours en pas
beaucoup de temps donc je dirais
je sais pas combien de temps ils peuvent
faire de partir en 30 minutes j'ai pas
exactement en fait tous les segments
sont préparés
attends il y a une excellente question
de Fat tout idemment ce qui se passe en
cas d'égalité
il y a quatre parties de Bullet
supplémentaires mais bon là ça va être
compliqué je pense pas que que
vous cache
récupère les 13 points que lui manque
dans cette portion de boulettes je pense
que même moi si je joue c'est pas
clairs
c'est quoi la plus grosse remontada de
l'histoire du speechers d'ailleurs genre
avoir une buvette là je sais pas non
plus et moins 13 et c'est sûr que non
non c'est impossible
en fait même techniquement si moi je
joue contre
un scène il va pas je pense pas
préserver
en une demi-heure il me l'avait pas il
va me mettre ouais tout neuf je pense
que tu sous-estime je sais pas non mais
bon après ça
moyen qui m'embête très en fait
si j'ai envie qu'il me les mettent pas
je la supporter
et aussi je l'estime beaucoup Barbie
t'inquiète pas
tu vois barbix dans mon estime par
l'estime que j'ai de lui et ben il est
pas là
il est beaucoup plus bas que ça
mais dans les cas ça m'a fait il va il
va tout me battre enfin toutes les
parties me battre en fait on sait pas
combien de parties là à faire
après si muscle une partie où
je prends
en jouant une minute contre 3 0 soit
qui est pas le temps en fait d'avoir la
question c'est pas que moi je vais
gagner une je sais que j'en ai zéro mais
la question c'est est-ce que je peux tu
vois
mon mauvais oui c'est sûr
que c'est perdu mais une plus une c'est
vraiment
plus zéro bah compte hein il y a il y a
13 parties à faire c'est 26 minutes le
match
pour ça que je pense que c'est pas clair
ça sera un bel enjeu faudra proposer
avec un scène c'est intéressant
parce que
il faut tout un pot qui réfléchissent
pas bon
hey Google
[Musique]
oui en fait non mais lui rappelle les
règles ça aurait pu hein
voilà juste je te rappelle si tu veux
abandonner tu peux faire
le pauvre franchement il passe un
mauvais gardien en fait je pense que les
trois erreurs malgré malgré toutes
toutes les défaites et tout ça
franchement tu vas être mauvaise langue
mais je pense qu'il kiffe
pas le verbe forcément
peu apprécier l'expérience avec recul
non mais voilà tu vois ce que je veux
dire en tout cas
il a pas kiffé
mais oui bien sûr ça reste cool le jeu
en tout cas il a gagné la dernière
partie donc il reste une victoire
il a pas fait dans le match de réussir à
ne pas perdre de partie de suite alors
est-ce que pour le pour le Bullet
sans nos caméras
pourquoi la caméra c'est une bonne
question
dans la vie
tellement vite
je sais pas pourquoi
et du coup est-ce que vous préférez du
coup la vue
est-ce que vous préférez la vue comme ça
la personne qui arrive tu as un la
caméra c'est un truc de fou
pour être vexé de votre réponse du coup
non mais en fait c'est chelou parce que
et oui du coup Alex grâce à cette
dernière victoire finalement il a fait
trois points donc quinzaine ne joue plus
pour battre le record de Naka voilà
après si on gagne plus il peut encore
peut-être créer un différentiel plus
important mais
donc à l'unanimité les gens préfèrent
avoir un hôtel
sauf à tout bon du coup on va vous
laisser comme ça
mais
un peu flou du coup quand on zoom
Barbie
qu'ils ont plus de pause
et du coup
c'est parti
allez c'est parti donc 47 noir dans
cette première partie
à l'égarden allez Google
et du coup c'est en Bullet et les gens
ils ont même éloins tu vois à peu près
mais je pense que après l'Arabie non il
a plutôt fait son boulot de tabarbitre
parce que ils ont clairement pas les
mêmes élans normalement
du coup pour éviter peut-être de se
faire trop attaquer ouais en fonction de
ce qui va se passer il va décider au bon
endroit ok donc là le 5 c'était assez
normal
essaie de faire le 5 ou 6 taper un peu
thématique tout ça
on dirait que tu n'as pas encore montré
tout ton savoir à Google donc s'il lui
manque encore un petit quelque chose
c'est-à-dire sûrement de la
F5 prise même 5 c'est pas débile ou il
le fait j'aime Google j'aime ce que tu
fais prise de sous va suivre après ou
pas parler de manger
pour l'instant coincé au centre et
Rocket ce serait évidemment côté
cimetière donc autant pour un justice
gratte
la punition la petite tactique car ça ne
l'a vu au moment où vous cache la jouer
et c'est mettre du couloir qui partait
donc du coup c'est une pièce nette de
plus pour goûter ce qui pourrait gagner
une deuxième partie de la filet
juste pas maintenant
après il faut que je le vide quand même
c'est pas encore bon c'est quand même
une pièce de plus il échange de dames
[Musique]
comment ça a mal tourné il s'est pris un
petit détroit de famille et le pion F
c'est un peu peur c'est parti
[Musique]
et il a 2 secondes contre 27 et il est
plus gagnant
[Musique]
parce que c'est passé très vite la
défense du Fou sur le cahier du coup ça
lui a coûté sa pièce de plus
faut c'est de très bien voilà
bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle pourquoi
de frayeur
après être revenu qu'il a refait une
connerie
c'est incroyable franchement mais c'est
là que tu vois un peu la différence
une pièce plus la taxe
il joue les coups de stouffe oui
use tous
un changement à la pose là on a remplacé
Google je pars tout
je pense qu'il serait vraiment gagnant
dans ce match
ça apportera pas de fraîcheur
non mais c'est hyper normal d'ailleurs
j'avais aussi l'autre contre un grand
maître c'est
la même idée
et c'est hyper intéressant
bien pour les blancs vous êtes partis
même si
il y a la colonne j'ai pour bien
d'autres truffé
encore un peu de jeu
il y a tous les pions qui tournent de
vrai au bouton attends mais il faut que
je change la caméra c'est vrai la raison
pour tout
sur ma carte contre Google
48 secondes est-ce que B3 c'est possible
des fois mais
sous une grosse pression au temps
grosse pression à tour B3 j'aime
beaucoup ce qui est
ok c'est changer
d'apprendre un tour ça marche ou pas ça
marche pas encore il va dame C8 sur Tour
Eiffel mais bon tu peux faire tu as une
ah non
excuse-moi
je double
il a abandonné alors tu peux prendre une
pièce sur échec
étrange pour abandonner mais voilà je
crois ouais bon il y a plus rien
[Musique]
il a fait mieux que déjà oui
et puis
à chaque fois en fait c'est marrant dans
tous les segments il y a eu un partout
et après
on va voir si la règle va être respectée
ouais alors
5 voir ce qui se passe en P3 c'est il
parle logique de la colonne à la colonne
CIF la B3 c'est b4c3 c'est pas la bonne
nouvelle pour pour Google j'ai
l'impression
mais
Griezmann excuse-moi on est on est à la
Coupe du Monde ou non ok j'arrête
j'ai pas compris tu me parles de grise
mine et moi je parle de Griezmann parce
qu'en ce moment
hier soir c'est
quoi hier soir
que c'était hier soir
juste comparer comparé par exemple ce
faux n'importe quelle fois adverse
d'ailleurs
très très bien pour les blancs qui va
arriver en trois peut-être
je pense mais
c'est ça reste très bon pour les Noirs
mais
c'est facile
électrique car la scène à la pause
donc un peu déçu quand même mais
sa nouvelle coupe de cheveux
alors du coup
encore une fois pour
pour caracène
que je veux absolument tout n'importe
quoi
et c'est pas ce qu'il y a de plus
n'importe quoi
il va falloir passer par F8 aussi je
pense
plutôt bien pour les Noirs j'aime bien
comme ça tu as des belles cases mais bon
et il a sacrifié la pièce où il a pris
Google c'est bien joué je pense en
pratique puisqu'il a une position F6
ça c'est quand même un peu un peu osé
mais bon
je sais pas si on annonce
[Musique]
malheureusement
chez nous et du coup j'ai pas vu sa tête
la promotion
il a poussé et en fait il joue à
et du coup ça pourrait bien se retourner
contre lui
un tour attention est un point qui est
du coup
parce que ce pion à 7 c'est une vraie
épée de Damoclès au-dessus de la tête
des Noirs
[Musique]
mais ok ça va trop vite
c'est très très tactique la pub 2
secondes car scène il échange les dames
alors il a récupéré sa pièce il a raté
ça
c'est un deuxième printer blanc qui va
très bien la victoire et cette fois
franchi en ligne d'arrivée et il va
tomber
sacrifice qui a payé finalement parce
qu'en pratique c'est pas si facile à
défendre très très dur
et oui j'ai déjà joué exactement la même
chose
il y a plus de 10 ans de partie avec le
roi qui part en D7 ouais
on avait joué d'abord j'ai 5 donc tu es
à l'époque plus ou moins de nouveautés
un maître fitter
moi je connaissais pas mais c'était
quand même bien passé et après je me
suis mis à jouer avec les noirs
c'était vraiment comme vous pouvez le
voir dans la position de faire exploser
le centre blanc les banques avec quatre
pions au centre au tout début et donc on
essaie d'ouvrir les lignes de sacrifier
des pions les pour
pour faire exploser le centre
alors ici j'ai pas commencé à tourner
c'est tout
personne qui est pris ou pas mal hein
[Musique]
ce qui voulait faire non plus bah après
il fallait des fins il y a un problème
sur l'option C7 il fallait éviter de le
perturer échec surtout
et malgré tout c'est une position très
décousue
des pièces qui s'échangent de manière
incongrue
en prise les cadres
mine de rien et les pièces noires ont
l'air quand même plus active et mieux
placé
plein de cadeaux
donc c'est vraiment
44 secondes après 26 coups
très très impressionnant car
quand on a l'intuition l'instinct de
carcassen on peut se permettre de
moins calculer
et je vais regarder à l'époque un truc
qui m'avait ultra impressionné c'est
qu'en fait quand je vois plus de ces 47
moi des fois ça m'arrivait à l'époque de
passer des soirées en fait alors garder
jouer
c'est genre il fait beaucoup de bullets
à l'époque sur les chaises et en fait il
est là il passe sa soirée à faire du
Bullet et c'est tellement impressionnant
que moi des fois je regardais et la
majorité c'est parti ils finissaient
comment dire
[Musique]
tu as la précision
alors sur le site c'était autre chose
c'était du
l'équivalent
avec des
comment ça s'appelle ça des
et
en gros bref moins tu en as plus tu te
souviens senti pion merci
en fait généralement généralement quand
agent
moins de 10 centipions c'est que bon on
te fait partie qu'elles sont parfaite
quoi genre
et lui quasiment toutes les parties il
faisait moins de 10 alors qu'ils ont
Bullet
il sait naturellement à quelqu'un
d'appartiennent ces pièces en fait c'est
tellement impressionnant le mec qui fait
du une
[Musique]
il y a quelques pions noirs qui sont
faibles aussi mais
il est ok au niveau de la pendule aussi
qu'est-ce qu'il a quelqu'un il y a une
tactique il va gagner peut-être
peut-être du matériel ou une qualité
comment ça se passe cavalier prend fou
de reprendre
la tour elle a un petit peu perchée
[Musique]
le jour en plus où tu arrives à presser
un peu Carlson et ben il te mange autant
quoi
c'est extrêmement difficile
c'est quand même un peu fixé un agréé
son tour de plus
il va devoir rendre le pion pour
s'activer le problème c'est que la tour
elle a pas de casse d'entrée c'est ce
que vous fait donc bah ça s'inverse
encore une fois ça tourne mal
et finalement de Tours pour l'instant
elles ont été
à sens unique depuis début de ce match
il est beaucoup plus rapide
[Musique]
c'est incroyable cette finale qui était
quand même à la base un petit peu mieux
pour ce bouquet comme ça ça a tourné en
faveur de cartes
et il se bat
les câbles sont pas bonnes
toujours pour l'activité aussi quitte à
perdre un peu c'est pas grave
ça fait 21 4 il reste 10 minutes du coup
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elle est blanche tout
effectivement
j'ai dû verser je suis désolé
tu es pardonné
et voilà on est bon
que la fin qu'on change de partie
un sèche-cheveux non mais en fait moi
j'ai le zoom ouvert et ça parle
je pense que la connexion
la connexion et les colères
après l'avantage
pas et pourtant il joue tout tu vois
même si il est déconnecté jusqu'à la fin
du match il gagnera quand même avec
avec 10 points d'avance
pourtant il est connecté tu vois son
zoom on va bien il est connecté
[Musique]
3 + 1 c'est 3 minutes plus une seconde
parcours 5 + 5 minutes plus une seconde
parcours et donc les gens en fait ils
sont affrontés avant dans ces différents
cadences pendant un temps donné
une heure et demie dans une heure
il vient de dire que
ça revient
il a perdu quoi
il parle plus
parce que
j'avais besoin
[Musique]
de la semaine dernière et c'était pas
arrivé depuis et bah là ça revient OK
[Musique]
la semaine dernière il avait des
problèmes similaires avec d'autres sites
et pas forcément quelque chose comme
encore une fois dans les autres dans
l'histoire des autres matchs à chaque
fois quand c'est passé comme ça juste
les mecs ils ont perdu les parties par
les connexions
après la partie maintenant
[Musique]
c'est un peu tard pour l'attaque
au niveau de l'ordinateur enfin il a un
temps
fonctionne je ne sais pas French caribou
c'est assez bizarre
[Musique]
j'ai jamais perdu comme ça
la scène du coup
j'aurais pu la changer avant quand même
il est vrai
et on voit qu'un récupérer c'est 4
barres de connexion ah ouais une bonne
nouvelle donc ça a l'air ok mais bon il
gagne dépité
on espère quand même qu'il y aura plus
de prêtres
[Musique]
et qu'il n'y ait pas de pause quand il
en avait et peut-être que il y avait
quand même beaucoup de départage j'aime
beaucoup des cas qui aime beaucoup
d'écart et puis aussi
[Musique]
avec H4 qui va partir aussi
Norvégiens sont les plus fermes c'est la
question
j'ai l'impression que ce deboutage sont
bien entraînés
pour trois pions un endroit complètement
à poil une trop cloué un cavalier cloué
faut juste éviter le mettre du couloir a
priori à un moment donné et ça devrait
bien se passer pour une cache non
attention
[Musique]
derniers
je pense
franchement je pense que c'est beaucoup
trop dur attention
[Musique]
un peu le match des mini bugs
c'est une Anglaise personne qui prime
move tout
je crois qu'il est un peu de terre
donne le pion
d'ailleurs c'est le match avait été le
même en lui il aurait pas eu d'un
créneau bah je pense pas que le score
beaucoup beaucoup évolué ça aurait été
un peu plus serré mais
il sera adapté évidemment mais
il y aura bien fallu un handicap comme
ça
ou qu'est-ce qui a été manger un pion du
coup il se retrouve dans des clouages il
faut qu'il arrive à se dépêtrer
de garder en fait
l'échange ici qu'elle va dépendre
qu'elle va les prendre sûrement
il reste toujours en vie mais comme tu
étais la première sur 15 blanche parce
que le Fou est parti la F4 attention F3
qui me fait un petit peu peur
aux conséquences quand même il peut y
avoir des trucs là il y a plein de
thèmes tactiques qui veulent arriver là
et les clouages un peu de partout on
peut dans tous les sens
prises
on pourrait répondre dans le chat à
krams
il a un peu désabusé ouais mais il a
toujours été comme ça
[Musique]
attention que tu peux pas trop trop
récupérer le Caval comme tu voulais la
dame doit être ça reste quand même
complètement gagnant non
un échec qui fait peur mais c'est tout
échec
encore plus fort
[Musique]
avec parmi nous et c'est dommage parce
que tout va parier 17 sur la victoire de
Google donc
c'est vraiment le match qu'il fallait
commenter Kevin tu t'es trompé
en tout cas Google qui a
qui a 297 en Bullet
qui a commencé avec 3260
[Musique]
un peu plus positive quand même après
avoir subi une longue séance de torture
ça doit être pire mais en fait après ok
il y a quand même du titre par rapport à
la connexion par rapport aussi à la
lassitude de ce match qui est très très
long et qui en fait ça fait longtemps
que ce match il est clairement de de
raison d'être et d'avoir qu'à l'inverse
quand tu perds comme ça tu as envie de
grappiller le plus de bien de possible
c'est ça donc du coup là je pense que
carcennes il est pas il a pas très très
motivé tu vois
les chevaux qui sont enfermés mais non
oui bien sûr mais bon il est pas focus
comme
exactement voilà
revenir sur des cases ici et sur F5 ou
F7
c'est plutôt sympa pour les blancs
j'aime bien en général
qui s'est terminé j'avais oublié
d'ailleurs de vous mettre encore une
fois le
le une plus une je vous le mets mais bon
va réussir à finir en beauté dans ce
match ça serait beau quand même une
petite victoire de la pour finir avec un
scène qui tape sur sa table il est pas
content mais je pense la connexion doit
quitter
position
il y a des possibilités et peut-être
trop de respect et un peu timide
c'est pas la Chine et du coup il a
permis avec Arsène de solidifier et
maintenant
[Musique]
qui sont catastrophiquement faibles ça a
l'air ça a l'air matelas et du coup ça
va être
je pense que tu ne le pars pas
et des deux pour essayer de revenir mais
tu vas quand même
et qui termine le match du coup
23 à 16h
du coup fin du match
fin du match 20 ans
23,7 donc car c'est régalé dans ce match
Google qu'est-ce qui est quand même bien
battu malgré malgré les difficultés
qu'il a rencontré parce que c'est quand
même pas facile même pour un même pour
un top joueur
qui était quand même globalement un
niveau stratosphérique il a fait très
très peu d'erreurs il est très bon
surtout dans les positions avec le money
time à chaque fois il a fait la
différence et vraiment impérial c'est un
petit peu relâché à la fin oui à la fin
que la connexion aussi il y avait des
problèmes un petit peu c'est plus
c'était pas évident mais bon il est
quand même rester un gros savon ça
grosse avance quand même carcène dans ce
score dans le score du match donc du
coup
Carl scène qui va rejoindre on peut le
voir sur la bracket Carlson qui va
rejoindre du coup en quart de finale
c'était du coup
mais pour ça il y a encore une étape à
franchir pour les deux hommes c'est ça
donc du coup on aura so et App Store qui
vont s'affronter
je crois que c'est
demain c'est ça rime demain ça va être
farine
et du coup jeudi on aura
le huitième de finale de saut adventure
of et aussi Nakamura contre par avion
donc là en tout cas pour la semaine
demain on a le match de
[Musique]
guéri donc on sera avec qui enfin je
serai avec Kevin taille un peu
off et Nakamura par avion je serai aussi
avec Kevin Tarrieux et ensuite vendredi
on aura du coup la le premier quart de
finale donc on ne sait pas encore qui on
verra et on ne sait pas encore à quelle
heure ça dépend des joueurs qui se
qualifient et de leur dispo donc donc
voilà en tout cas demain 17h ça rime
guéri donc le vainqueur de ce matelas
rencontrera d'ingly Rennes en quart de
finale donc déjà des gros chocs girim
qui est dans le top 10 mondial depuis
maintenant presque 10 ans et
ça rime qui est la jeune le jeune jeune
star montante 18 ans forcément 2700 et
le feed et sur Internet c'est quand même
un des meilleurs joueurs de circuit
merci tout pour toutes ces précisions et
on remercie tous ceux qui nous ont suivi
et toutes celles dans le dans le chat
pour leur commentaire et
du coup si on peut conclure tout je
pense donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi de
stream comme d'habitude merci à toi
s'amus d'être venu commenter avec moi ce
match et du coup on vous dit à demain
même heure pour farine guéri